redonner de l'oxygène aux soignants
c'est l'objectif du plan d'urgence
dévoilé ce matin le gouvernement se dit
à l'écouté de la colère de l'épuisement
et du désarroi de l'hôpital public
son remède un milliard et demi de budget
en plus sur trois ans est-ce suffisant
et l'exécutif at-il cibler les bonnes
priorités ce notre débat dans un instant
enfin les nerfs au coeur des inquiétudes
du sénat à quelques mois des municipales
les élus locaux sont rassemblés en
congrès cette semaine à paris hier le
discours d' emmanuel macron ne les a pas
convaincus
on y revient tout à l'heure et n'hésitez
pas à commenter à réagir 7 à cette
émission avec le hashtag qu à g et on va
tout de suite rejoindre quentin qu'elle
met dans l'hémicycle du sénat je disais
au sommaire de cette question
d'actualité au gouvernement
il va y avoir les maires mais il va
aussi d'avoir des questions consacré à
l'hôpital quand un oui notamment avec
cette question très attendu du président
de la commission des affaires sociales
alain milon sur ces mesures annoncées
tout à l'heure par edouard philippe et
agnès buzyn edouard philippe qui va être
destinataire de cette question à pouvoir
préciser les annonces que ce soit sur ce
plan d'urgence avec ses primes pour le
personnel ou encore la rallonge de 1 5
milliard d'euros et la reprise de 10
milliards d'euros de la dette de pia
public
mais déjà certains sénateurs de droite
ont dénoncé sur twitter les mesures de
rafistolage je cite bruno retailleau le
patron des sénateurs a l'air et qui a
dénoncé le fait qu'il n'y avait aucune
réorganisation et des investissements et
des revalorisations un minima aucune
vision pour l'hôpital a dit bruno
retailleau
le ton est donc donné pour cette
question dlr d'hôtes entame que ses
annonces sur l'hôpital elles
interviennent dans un contexte tendu
entre le gouvernement et le sénat sur
séché sur ces sujets de la santé
la chambre haute du parlement a rejeté
la semaine dernière le budget de la sécu
car il manquait tout ces annonces sur
l'hôpital public
les sénateurs ne vont donc pas manquer
de rappeler au gouvernement que la
discussion sur la santé des français
elle aurait dû se tenir dans l'hémicycle
la semaine dernière merci beaucoup
quentin pour toutes ces explications et
vous l'avez dit c'est l'un des temps
forts annoncés pour cette question
d'actu et pour la journée le plan de
sauvetage de l'hôpital après le jeudi
noir des blouses blanches la semaine
dernière emmanuel macron a déclaré avoir
entendu la colère des soignants et a
annoncé un plan d'action
hélas été détaillé ce matin par edouard
philippe et agnès buzyn la ministre des
solidarités et de la santé cécile
section pour sauver l'hôpital le
gouvernement a sorti le portefeuille est
le premier gagnant est le budget des
hôpitaux qui devrait augmenter de 1,5
milliard d'euros sur trois ans dont 3
100 millions dès 2020 ces sommes
viennent en plus de la trajectoire
budgétaire prévu par le gouvenement par
le gouvernement
cette augmentation sera donc proposé et
je l'espère adopté dès la semaine
prochaine dans le cadre du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
les bas salaires des personnels
hospitaliers seront également
revalorisée 600 mille professionnels
pourront bénéficier d'une prime au
mérite annuel de 300 euros et 40000
aides soignants et infirmiers de la
région parisienne qui gagnent moins de
1900 euros par mois tous feront une
prime de 800 euros par an nous devons
faire connaître la situation spécifique
de paris et de la petite couronne où les
coûts de logement sont très élevées et
où le tissu hospitalier et danse avec
des phénomènes de concurrence entre
établissements sur le recrutement
les soignants sont ainsi soumis à des
suggestions particulière horaires
étendus garde transport qui pèse de
manière déraisonnable
l'état compte également reprendre 10
milliards d'euros de dettes des hôpitaux
sur trois ans soit un tiers de
l'ensemble de la dette actuellement de
30 milliards d'euros
l'objectif pour le gouvernement est de
restaurer les équilibres financiers des
établissements hospitaliers
c'est un geste fort pour l'hôpital
public au service d'une idée simple que
les communautés hospitalières puisse se
concentrer sur leur métier
le soin au lieu de s'épuiser à
rembourser des emprunts simplifier les
recrutements permettre la vaccination en
pharmacie ou encore contrôler le recours
à l'intérim
gouvernement souhaite également réformer
et simplifier l'organisation interne des
hôpitaux alors le remède est il à la
hauteur du mal-être hospitalier on en
parle avec quatre invités sur ce plateau
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir pour ce
débat laurence cohen bonjour bonjour
vous êtes sénatrice communiste du val de
marne vice présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales également avec
nous martha lévriers jour jour sénateurs
lrm des yvelines également membre de la
commission des affaires sociales bernard
jomier vous êtes sénateur écologiste
apparenté au groupe social de paris
membre de la commission des affaires
sociales est également nous sommes avec
jean marie vanlerenberghe sénateur uc du
pas-de-calais rapporteur général de la
commission des affaires sociales budget
de la sécurité sociale
première question pour vous laurence
cohen sur et bien ces annonces ce matin
du premier ministre et de la ministre de
la santé
pas mal de primes qui ont été annoncées
pour les salaires les plus faibles mais
pas d'augmentation générale est ce que
pour vous c'est suffisant mais d'abord
je veux saluer la mobilisation des
personnels de santé soignants et non
soignants
parce que les annonces d'aujourd'hui
sont la résultante du combat qui a duré
pendant huit mois et qui à mon avis va
continuer parce qu'effectivement les
mesures si elles vont dans le bon sens
puisqu'il ya un petit plus ce ne sont
pas du tout suffisante
et puis la prime qui est annoncée de 800
euros ne correspond absolument pas à ce
qu'attendent les personnels c'est une
revalorisation des salaires une
augmentation des salaires et je dois
dire qu une prime de 800 euros 800 euros
de prime annuelle pour 40000 infirmiers
aides soignants
il dort en offrant soit là et je veux
dire que si vous faites un calcul c'est
en dessous ça fait à peu près 60 6 euros
par mois
c'est en dessous du passe navigo
puisqu'on parle de l'île de france donc
ça ne fait pas le compte
et en plus ils essayent d'opposer les
personnels entre eux il faut il
augmenter les augmentations de salaires
pardon pour tous les personnels jean
marie vanlerenberghe votre avis serait
bien ces annonces en parlera des grands
équilibres de la sécurité sociale
ensuite mais d'abord sur ces annonces
qui sont là pour restaurer
l'attractivité de l'hôpital public sont
des mesures concrètes de pouvoir d'achat
pour les personnalités vie donc je vais
pas avoir tout à fait le même point de
vue que le roscouet
je trouve que on a remis un peu d'humain
dans dans le projet hospitalier donc je
trouve que c'est une bonne chose ça
l'est je crois qu'il faut le saluer
certes c'est sans doute pas à la mesure
de ce qui attendait les syndicats les
personnels hospitaliers
mais qui peut dire et depuis fort
longtemps avoir apporté effectivement
autant à l'hôpital ça va être une
revalorisation quand même considérable
de l'ondam qui va passer à 2004 c'est
300 millions cette année ça va être un
milliard cinq sur trois ans ce n'est pas
négligeable même si c'est en deçà de ce
que pouvait espérer légitimement
d'ailleurs mais le problème c'est qu'ils
financent comment effectivement on
arrive à apporter ça à l'hôpital quand
on sait qu'il ya d'autres problèmes qui
a pas que le problème de l'assurance
maladie a pas que le problème de
l'hôpital dans le financement de la
sécurité sociale
on l'a vu il ya deux jours avec le
rapport du cor sur les retraites il y à
aussi effectivement des problèmes dont
vous voyez c'est un tout et nous aurons
l'occasion évidemment d'en débattre à
nouveau bientôt dans le plfss
on va parler de tout cela et des grands
équilibres du budget mais d'abord je
voudrais qu'on revient d'un petit peu
sur les mesures annoncées ce matin à
revalorisation notamment et bien pour
les aides-soignants pour les internes et
je voudrais juste que l'on regarde tout
de même aujourd'hui le salaire d'un
infirmier dans l'hôpital public en début
de carrière de 1650 euros brut par mois
2796 euros brut par mois au dernier
échelon et regardez ce graphique on voit
que le salaire des infirmiers et bach
par rapport à la moyenne de nombreux
pays de l' ocde bien en dessous il ya
borné en dessous de la moyenne de l'os
et 2e en tout la grèce du royaume uni
devant ont néanmoins la lituanie martin
lévriers il était tout de même plus que
temps de faire un geste mais ce n'est
qu'une prime
eh bien je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous il était grand temps de faire
un geste et j'ai apprécié plusieurs
choses avant de rentrer dans ce débat là
c'est les paroles du premier ministre
qui a parlé de communauté hospitalière
ça qu'on parle pas que d'argent on parle
pas
que de financement on parle d'une
communauté d'hommes et de femmes qui
travaillent ensemble des soignants c'est
à dire de toutes les personnes les
femmes et les hommes qui y travaillent
ensemble au service des patients ne les
oublions jamais l'hôpital c'est pour les
patients avant tout on doit parler des
patients et pour que les patients aille
mieux il faut bien évidemment que la
communauté fonctionne beaucoup mieux et
c'est ce qui me paraît important dans ce
plan bien sûr il sait jamais suffisant
mais on revient de tellement loin de si
loin de cela je vais pas refaire
l'historique parce qu'on est tous
d'accord sur l'historique mais en via de
très très loin aujourd'hui des très gros
moyens sont mis ils ne sont pas mis que
sur le financier ils sont mis sur les
moyens humains par des primes c'est vrai
et pas des salaires ce sont des primes
je vous je vous accorde des primes mais
est-ce qu'il faut toujours plus plus
plus est ce qu'il vaut pas une
réorganisation ou si on en parle je
pense que c'est un ensemble de choses
donc on est dans la continuité de ma
santé 2022 et je trouve ça très positif
bernard un jeu mais est ce que vous
voyez le verre à moitié vide ou le verre
à moitié plein moi je vois qu'on est
mercredi 20 novembre et que mardi 19 on
a voulu nous faire voter un père effet
c'est ce qui n'est déjà plus d'actualité
c'est un budget la sienne a été
nationale qui est caduc et donc
heureusement que le sénat le sénat a eu
raison de refuser ce vote
maintenant moi ce qui me ce qui me
marque dans les annonces c'est que il ya
un certain volume d'argent qui apportait
qui a annoncé sur trois ans a réduit
quand même les sommes annuelles
on veut nous faire un effet quand même
d'optique un peut même dire que c'est de
bonne guerre sauf que sauf que la
situation la situation est grave et que
on sait aussi que la réponse elle n'est
pas que financière donc on a une part de
réponse financière
pour résumer et ne pas seulement sané ça
n'est pas suffisant et c'est pas un gros
mot de dire que c'est pas suffisant
c'est vrai qu'elle quelques l argent
notre pays doit consacrer à l'hôpital et
à son système de santé c'est un débat
qu'on a jamais on dit on consomme trop
de la part de notre richesse d'agen à
santé moi je dis que non on doit on doit
en débattre
on doit en débattre sans tabou et la
deuxième chose c'est que l'hôpital
souffre de bien d'autres choses
il souffre d'une crise de sens que font
les personnages qu est ce qu on demande
à l'hôpital public dans notre pays
qu'est ce qu'on lui demande de faire ou
de ne pas faire qu'elles doivent être
ses missions qu'elle doit être
l'engagement de ses personnels
quelles doivent être les organisations
et là quand même ce matin on n'a pas une
réponse
il ya eu quand même des mois pour
remettre le fanion au coeur alors ça
ceux de l'hôpital des mots on a eu des
mots mais attendez pardon on demande à
un gouvernement d actes lemos a fait ils
ont tous été prononcées depuis des
années par tout le monde
y'a pas de problème mais là on a besoin
on a besoin d'actes on a besoin de
savoir dans les missions de l'hôpital
prenez la question des urgences la
ministre nous dit ça y est le dossier de
la permanence des soins
là on va y aller on va le travail et
enfin pardon c'est pas nouveau on l'a on
l'a dit au moment de la loi santé on a
voté des choses dans la loi santé
d'ailleurs sur cette question là donc il
est temps maintenant de passer aux actes
et de nous dire que le gouvernement nous
dise clairement ce qu'il veut faire en
la matière de la paix il est pas trop
tard et de la pertinence des soins
d'ailleurs il ya effectivement des
annonces qui sont faites dans ce plan je
pense aussi
on l'a pas dit mais il ya 300 euros
primes annuelles c'est peut-être peu
mais ça concerne tous les personnels
oui inkling c'est pas forcément et
surtout en 1000 personnels et les 800
accordé par mois et les 100 euros par
mois pour les soignants qui sont
affectés aux personnes âgées
ça me paraît très important lors
honnêtement ça ce que c'est vraiment là
tout devient rejoint par les hôpitaux
aussi très bien besoin il ya un besoin
quand même considérable de d'apporter
aux personnes âgées
effectivement toute l'aide et toute la
la sollicitude dont ils ont besoin et
donc ça ça ne peut être fait que par des
soignants qui effectivement aujourd'hui
ont une charge considérable et qu'il ne
pouvait charger
je ne dirais pas qu'on va dédommager la
générosité l'affection ça n'a pas de
prix mais je crois qu'il était important
de reconnaître la charge de travail
quand même qu'elles ont ces personnes
souvent ce sont des femmes
à quels sont à l'égard effectivement des
personnes les plus âgées un mot laurence
quand même et puis on va aller en salle
dès qu'on va pas quand même plus qu'un
mot parce que c'est un langage que je
considère comme hypocrite c'est à dire
qu'il ya huit mois de lutte des
personnels il ya un ras-le-bol
considérable parce que l'hôpital est en
souffrance les personnels sont en
souffrance
les patients sont en souffrance
et ce sont des miettes qui sont accordés
pourquoi je dis que ce sont des miettes
qui se sont accordés je suis absolument
désolé prédisent que ça représentait par
par mois c'est pas une prime dont ont
besoin ces personnels ils ont besoin
d'augmentation de salaire parce que une
prime par exemple ça ne compte pas pour
les retraites parce que une la prime ne
compte pas sur la pénibilité du travail
c'est aussi la deuxième chose que je
veux dire et la troisième chose de mes
chers collègues c'est que quand même ce
qui se passe avec les fermetures de lits
c'est en une vingtaine d'années ces cent
mille îles ont été fermées aujourd'hui
les chefs de service les les soignants
crie au secours
il va y avoir là il ya il a le début de
la bronchiolite 1 et bien il ya des
médecins comme le docteur le professeur
salomon de necker dit qu'il n'y a pas de
lits pour les enfants et on les envoie à
droite et à gauche et vous pensez que
c'est une question de réorganisation on
en est quand même je termine on en est
quand même au quatrième plan en 14 mois
ben franchement qu agnès buzyn est
attendu autant de temps et qu'elle
n'écoute pas ni la voix des
parlementaires ni la voix des
syndicalistes
c'est une faute très grave on va en
parler tout de suite je vous promets que
dans les salles des conférences parce
que l'on va rejoindre bien l'une de vos
collègues catherine de roche n'attriste
l air et rapporteur du budget de
l'assurance maladie elle est un autre
micro alexandre poussin
pour elle c'est une réaction et oui
catherine de roche vous examiner de près
ce budget de l'assurance maladie
est ce que cette rallonge budgétaire est
suffisante selon c'est mieux que la
semaine dernière évidemment puisque nous
étions sur un objectif de dépenses
d'assurance maladie pour le secteur
hospitalier est à 2-1 mais ça reste
néanmoins inférieur aux tendancielle des
dépenses des établissements donc ce qui
veut dire que même avec un ondam a
augmenté de avec cet objectif augmenter
300 millions d'euros pour 2020 on
demande néanmoins toujours des économies
au secteur hospitalier puisque les
dépenses devraient croître de façon
beaucoup plus élevé donc il aurait fallu
une rallonge budgétaire encore plus
grande il aura fallu sans doute une
rallonge budgétaire encore plus grande
on nous annonce un million cinq sur
trois ans avec un ennui leur parle en
milliards 5 sur trois ans avec un coup
de pouce en 2022
comme par hasard juste l'année des
élections non on sait que les besoins
sont énormes alors c'est vrai que
l'équation budgétaire est compliqué mais
néanmoins on reste dans quelque chose
qui est mieux que ce qu'on nous demande
d'être votée c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que nous avions refusé de voter la
semaine dernière mais c'est néanmoins
sûrement insuffisant alors un tiers de
la dette de l'hôpital va être reprise
par l'état
ça va encore alourdir la dette de la
france alors la dette oui en effet en
reprend un tiers la dette est à peine 30
milliards là on en reprend 10 milliards
il faut attendre que le gouvernement
nous explique comment il va financer
cette reprise de la dette
vraisemblablement par une aggravation en
effet de la dette publique
comment on pourrait financer cette
reprise de la dette on pense que notre
groupe ans que concernant les secteurs
hospitalier secteurs la santé en général
on est sur des budgets successifs qui
sont la reconduite avec des ajustements
chaque année mais pratiquement chaque
année du même dispositif nous ce que
nous souhaitons c'est véritablement des
états généraux de la santé en france
pour voir en effet quelles sont les
stratégies que l'on met sur plusieurs
années concernant ce budget de la
sécurité sociale mais pourtant le
gouvernement a fait une grande loi
d'organisation du système de santé donc
ça ce n'est pas suffisant oui il a fait
le mode d'organisation du cem la santé
mais quand elle se traduit dans les
budgets notamment lors du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
on voit bien que les mesures qui sont
votées sont des rustines par rapport à
ce qui était à ce qu'étaient les besoins
et ne correspondent pas aux annonces
faites donc en fait à chaque fois on
court derrière les financements pour
répondre aux objectifs des lois que l'on
a voté très bien il faut plus que des
rustines pour sauver l'hôpital français
merci beaucoup
catherine de roche pour votre réaction
merci beaucoup alexandre alors est ce
que ces rustines
est-ce que ce plan ainsi détail répond à
l'urgence va-t-il permettre de répondre
au cri d alarme de l'hôpital public et
de tous ses personnels en souffrance
retour sur des mois de contestation avec
amical spitzberg
le diagnostic est ancien mais le
gouvernement peine à trouver le bon
traitement
après huit mois de crise l'hôpital
public n'en finit plus d'exprimer son
mal être
une colère qui se traduit par une grève
inédite qui touche aujourd'hui 268
établissements
avec toujours les mêmes revendications
hausse des salaires augmentation des
effectifs et réouvertures de lits dont
le nombre a diminué de près de 15 % en
15 ans une fronde qui touche toutes les
professions médicales
moi je suis médecin est ce que je veux
c'est des infirmiers des aides soignants
au lit du malade c'est ça qui compte
le reste ça n'a aucune importance
traduisez sans argent je ne sais pas
c'est pas mon boulot face aux mouvements
la ministre de la santé a tenté de
rassurer à coude enveloppe 70 millions
d'euros cet été pour revaloriser les
salaires dans les urgences 750 millions
sur trois ans en septembre pour
désengorger ces mêmes urgence mais sans
lit ni effectifs supplémentaires
trop peu pour un personnel de santé à
bout de souffle et qui oblige le
gouvernement à revoir sa copie son plan
ma santé 2022 présenté à la rentrée 2010
8 une stratégie globale pour le système
de santé français
c'est un plan là aussi beaucoup plus
large qui doit répondre à la situation
actuelle nous devons investir et assumée
d'investir plus fortement en avion au
début envisager de le faire parce que la
situation est encore plus grave que
celle que nous avions analysé une
opération spéciale de déminage alors que
les internes menace d'une grève
illimitée à partir du 10 décembre
martin a lévriers votre réaction à ce
que disait se manifestant dans le
reportage de michael spitzberg
il parle certes de hausse des salaires
mais par sont tous deux des effectifs et
des lits et là dessus il dit suis en
train de fournir supprime est important
c'est qu'il y ait plus de personnes pour
s'occuper des malades j'entends ça et
moi je lui réponds certes d'abord
n'oublions pas que nous avons un des
meilleurs systèmes de santé au monde il
faut aussi relativiser un peu même si la
crise est grave je m'épanouis et il
était depuis 20 ans maltraité nous c'est
pas mauvais non plus depuis 20 ans on
court après des difficultés et
maltraités je ne pense pas que des
gouvernants se soit amusé à essayer d'
abîmer l'hôpital simplement des choix
ont été faits qui n'étaient peut-être
pas les bons mais pape ou alors changez
pas dire que les choix pour les avaient
pas pour la vie mais je pense pas moi ce
que je retiens et ça c'est important
c'est qu'on peut pas dire il n'ya besoin
que des personnes il ya besoin
d'investissements pas je viens du
secteur privé pas de l'hôpital privé
secteur privé une entreprise ne
fonctionne pas sans investissement et on
investit c'est quasiment plus
quand on parle de l'itie on disait à ce
médecin d'accord mais vous malades sur
un brancard il dirait vous êtes fous
donc il faut les deux
cet ensemble comprend qu'au temps
reprend la tête alors je reprends un peu
moins ce que dit madame de roche tout à
l'heure sur la dette la dette est une
dette de l'état dont il n'y a pas de
surprise ce qui va alléger le problème
de l'hôpital c'est qu'il n'aura plus à
rembourser les 1 850 millions exactement
pour la totalité de la dette donc un
tiers 250 millions 260 280 de miroirs
donc liberté supplémentaire pour
dépenser ou pour investir donc pour
payer des primes ou pour investir ce qui
est essentiel aujourd'hui jean marie
vanlerenberghe
on le voit tout de même bien vous parler
d'investissements mais c'est pas du tout
sûr que ça suffise à calmer la grogne
quand on voit et bien les autres
demandes du personnel soignant
oui vous soulignez tout à l'heure le la
nécessité de revoir effectivement
l'organisation de l'hôpital
l'organisation et la place de l'hôpital
dans le système de santé aujourd'hui et
moi j'ai visité l'allemagne on a un
système de santé à ses comparables
la part de l'hôpital bien moindre que
celle que nous avons en france au profit
des médecins de ville
donc il ya un problème de rééquilibrage
et on le voit bien quand il s'agit de
permanence des soins
la permanence des soins n'est plus
suffisamment assurée par les personnels
les médecins elle est donc ça se
reportent sur l'hôpital d'où cet
engorgement dans certaines certains
certains secteurs certains hôpitaux
c'est pas le cas chez moi c'est pas le
cas chez moi oui j'ai et on a concentré
on a véritablement concentré je dirai
tout la communication sur les urgences
dans les hôpitaux de la région
parisienne mais la situation très
contrastée suivant effectivement les
régions donc il faut aussi prendre en
compte
je suis totalement d'accord sur le fait
que l'organisation de l'hôpital est
essentiel parce que les urgences en soit
s'il n'y a pas derrière effectivement
des lits dans les services et des
médecins qui sont en capacité
effectivement d'organiser d'où
l'importance aussi qu'il ya dans ce plan
qui est attachée à la gouvernance que
les médecins par exemple c'est peut-être
symbolique mais ça peut à terme avoir
des effets c'est que les médecins vont
pouvoir à nouveau
diriger des hôpitaux c'est que les
médecins et le président de la
commission médicale va pouvoir
conjointement avec le directeur désigné
les chefs de pôle ça peut changer
considérablement le management et
l'organisation de l'hôpital et ça il
faut le souligner bernard jaume i est ce
que ça ces mesures là elle vous elle
vous satisfont de remettre et bien le
médecin au coeur de l'hôpital c'est ce
qu'il a dit edouard philippe
effectivement ce matin pour aller à
l'encontre d'un fonctionnement at-il dit
trop bureaucratique aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya des lois notamment
la loi bachelot qui ont donné beaucoup
plus de pouvoir bien au directeur
administratif et peut-être pas assez aux
médecins d'abord ce pas que le médecin
c'est les soignants et les seniors il
faut quand même pas avoir une vision
trop centrés que ça aimé ça mais c'est
vrai que si les médecins quittent
l'hôpital public de façon importante en
ce moment c'est pas eux
pour des questions de rémunération
vraiment c'est longue date qu'il ya une
moins dans le public que dans le privé
c'est beaucoup pour des questions de
gouvernance et d'organisation du travail
alors que les personnels ça c'est un
vrai problème
elle de rémunération parce qu'ils
sentent que le sens de leur mission est
perdu et que l'organisation qui a été
mis en place
qui sait on va lire aggravée depuis la
loi hôpital patients santé territoires
la loi de roselyne bachelot en 2010 a
considérablement aggravé ce phénomène là
mais moi je suis désolé mais sur les
annonces qui ont été faites aujourd'hui
c'est très faible sans la question c'est
très très faible on en reste à le
médecin chef d'établissement ça a été
annoncé lors du plan ma santé 2022 par
le chef de l'état est par ailleurs c'est
plus symbolique qu'autre chose parce que
les médecins ne veulent pas diriger
hôpitaux ils veulent pouvoir soigner le
chirurgien il veut que quand ils
arrivent à 7h et 7h30 au bloc le matin
il est le matériel qu'il a choisi pour
opérer il est le patient qu'ils soient
là et qu'ils soient prêts et bien
souvent ça n'est plus le cas voilà et ça
ça n'est pas possible de continuer comme
ça sas n'a fait que s'aggraver
et c'est ça qui doit être changé c'est
ça qui doit être modifié problème
redonner un cadre d'exercices qui soit
rien que ça pour valorisant et par
ailleurs les deux conventions par
ailleurs là où je suis d'accord et
l'exemple des urgences de ventre très
bien c'est que l'hôpital ne se pense pas
seul il ne se pense pas en dehors du
système de santé
et là aussi il y à il ya un défaut quand
je dis que le train
vas y sont les missions n'est toujours
pas abordé de façon nette et claire
qu'est ce qu'on demande à l'hôpital de
faire ou de ne pas faire
laurence cohen vous qui avec le parti
communiste avait fait un tour de france
des hôpitaux quelques est ce que vous
aviez constaté sur place le manque de
moyens le manque d'investissement
comment ça se traduit dans les actes eux
m'en sers que je m'inscris en faux avec
ce qui est ce qui a été dit parce que
nous on a fait plus de 160
établissements publics que ce soit les
hôpitaux ou les ehpad partout partout la
même constatation et je dirais du du
directeur et de la directrice de
l'hôpital jusqu'à l'aide soignant et c
c'est à dire on est arrivé au bout des
économies qu'on peut exiger d'un hôpital
c'est la première premières
constatations c'est pas une histoire
il peut y avoir réorganisation etc mais
c'est pas ça l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est qu'il faut arrêter de
faire des économies au niveau de
l'hôpital parce que on parle là d'une
augmentation de 2 de l'ondam on dit
qu'elle est insuffisant mais j'ai repris
logiques nationales donné leur relation
voilà là il va être portée à 2,45 pour
cent et ils étaient prévus dans le plfss
où vous rappeler à 2,1
mais mes chers collègues faut se
remettre un petit peu les idées en place
en 2019 vous avez voté une augmentation
de 2,5 donc alors que l'hôpital est en
crise que ça fait huit mois que les
personnels se battent la ministre tout
heureuse et rayonnante qui s'est quand
même un petit peu moqué nous au niveau
de l'hémicycle en nous présentant un
budget qui était plutôt un sincère elle
dit aurait qu'un ça y est de 2,45
elle est en dessous de ce qui était
promis qu'elle n'était pas remis l'année
dernière et quand on parle du personnel
j'aimerais bien aussi qu'on envisage le
problème des des paramédicaux qui crie
aussi aux secours alors ce que vous
dites dans une prime et c'est pas ça
pour qu'il y ait une attractivité pour
au niveau de ses métiers
il faut augmenter absolument les
salaires et moi je vais donner tout de
suite un moyen et après comme ça je
laisse la place aux débats de l'argent
c'est une question de choix
c'est la cour des comptes c'est pas le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
qui l'écologie ce qu'il a dit c'est sur
les niches sociales 90 milliards d'euros
et par rapport aux allées
je mens d'exonérations de cotisations
etc
on pourrait récupérer à peu près 60
milliards d'euros si je ne me trompe pas
avec avec les chiffres donc vous voyez
que de larges 52 milliards gt c'est ce
que je me disais c'est pas 66 et 52 52
milliards atteint 52 milliards pour
notre système de santé ça serait
bienvenue donc il faut arrêter
d'exonérer et il faut remettre cet
argent là dans le circuit de la santé
pour répondre aux besoins
voilà pour la solution par laurence
klein pas là pour que tout le monde
sache bien de quoi on parle
je propose quand même que l'on écoute
puisque vous en avez parlé et bien le
moment de cette intervention d'edouard
philippe lorsqu'il a bien expliqué et
bien comment ils proposaient de
desserrer la ceinture de l'hôpital et
les moyens qui sont à attribuer en
l'écoutant 10 milliards sur trois ans et
3 milliards 3 chaque année qui
permettront de rétablir de restaurer
l'équilibré financier des établissements
une loi sera présenté au premier
semestre 2020 en même temps que la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
qui doit intervenir à l'occasion du
premier semestre 2020 et qui permettra
de corriger notre trajectoire et de
prendre en compte
techniquement la façon de calibrer cette
reprise de dettes et de la compagnie
cette reprise de dette
elle permettra aux hôpitaux de réduire
leurs déficits et de retrouver
rapidement les moyens d'investir pour
moderniser les hôpitaux actuels
accompagner les transformations que
meudon redonner les marges de manoeuvre
nécessaires à l'ensemble des personnels
hospitaliers pour qu'ils puissent
travailler dans des conditions
satisfaisantes
martin est lévriers donc un milliard et
demi sur trois ans en 2019 2022
et puis aussi cette reprise de la dette
par celle de l'hôpital 10 milliards sur
trois ans qui s combine visées sur ces
10 milliards sur trois ans les hôpitaux
les plus endettés les hôpitaux selon le
biberon des deux bords à montréal et je
crois si tout le monde ne défende en
fonction je pense là je ne suis pas dans
le secret des dieux mais j'imagine qu'on
veut le faire en fonction de leur projet
d'abord de la dette qu'ils ont et de la
capacité de projets qu'ils ont derrière
pour relancer leur hôpital et l'aurait
améliorer s'il est un endroit en
difficulté voilà je pense que c'est le
point le plus simple et le plus évident
qu'ils
doit être fait c'est tout le monde ne
demande que quelques uns à quelles vont
être les critères ça va être quand même
je vous répondrais personne ne pouvait
le demander aujourd'hui puisqu'on ne
reprendrai pas la dette si vous voulez
c'est toujours le même débat se soit on
fait rien et personne ne demande rien
soit on fait tout et tout le monde est
content soit on trouve un bon équilibre
parce que je rappelle quand même que la
france est en déficit et qu'il faut
faire attention qu'on veut mettre de
l'argent partout
est ce que disait ma collègue tout à
l'heure sur sur ce côté là est
intéressant mais on peut pâtir imaginez
quand on supprime les niches en une
seconde qu'on supprime tous les
problèmes en une seconde et qu'on
récupère cet argent ça serait trop
simple et trop facile il ya d'autres
sujets on peut faire des économies et
moi je vous rejoins complètement là
dessus cette recherche qu'on a à faire
des économies
il ya les actes les actes inutiles qui
sont répétés 80 milliards 100 milliards
on ne sait plus très bien combien il ya
beaucoup de points où on peut faire des
économies c'est vrai ici c'est ce que
dit c'est vraiment une belle il ya
environ nous sur l'assurance maladie
mais bon c'est cet ensemble c'est
ensemble mais je reviens si vous voulez
à ce qui était le sait pas plus les
procédures administratives berthod et le
fait de bien travailler ensemble parce
que dans un hôpital ce qui fonctionne
c'est aussi gilles du torse et la
communauté hospitalière
et quand on donne les moyens à la
direction de l'hôpital de pouvoir donner
des primes
assez assez soignants je trouve que
c'est très intéressant on ré rouvre le
débat au niveau horizontal
oui mais on est aussi les primes c'est
si on vous faisait ça vous au niveau de
salaire et je les fais chier on vivait
très bien pour seulement fermé
bénéficier
c'est parce que demandent les personnels
il faut peut-être un petit peu écoutés
personnel et 8 mois qu'ils se battent
sur sa fais pas le con
puis moi qui se battent se fera quinze
ans qu'ils y étiez d'accord ça ça fait
du buzz il ya quinze ans elle est passée
d'un client le temps des créations
d'emplois parce qu'on arrive au bout du
bout que c'est ici qu'on a baissé le
temps de travail sans compenser et
c'était un gouvernement de gauche qui a
fait ça et donc je crois que l'hôpital
bien sûr parce qu'il est apple n'y a pas
une compensation ya surtout par des
embauches
bien sûr oui eh bah alors oui mais c'est
un gouvernement qui a fait ça et bail
alors il ya gauche et gauche la gauche
on peut refaire toute l'histoire et
s'envoyer à la figure et tous qui a
dysfonctionné l'hôpital et les erreurs
qui ont été faites la réalité c'est que
il ya une situation aujourd'hui est un
gouvernement qui est en place qui est
légitime pour apporter des réponses
est ce que le plan d'urgence est un plan
qui va répondre à la situation
non il a des éléments positifs ce plan
c'est indéniable c'est indéniable il ya
des éléments positifs mais ce qui
répondra non la situation est telle à
l'hôpital y est tellement de choses à
régler on voit bien qu'il ya pas une
mesure qui permet de remettre l'hôpital
en bon état de santé de soigner
l'hôpital comme ils le méritent et donc
il faut mettre tout le monde autour de
la table
le fait de vouloir faire des états
généraux de l'hôpital c'est pas une
posture c'est pas vain parce qu'on a une
âme de révolutionnaire c'est parce que
l'on pleure l'ampleur de ce qui est à
changer à l'hôpital nécessite que tout
le monde soit écouté soit miauton la
table participent à la discussion et que
la communauté nationale
est-ce que voilà une communauté qui est
important de la communauté nationale
ces représentants ces élus disent les
moyens qu'ils veulent consacrée à
l'hôpital est encore une fois quelle est
sa place dans notre système de santé
on a un système hospitalier qui est
important non il faut sourire 2020 il
faut lire oui oui mais ma santé 2022
c'est bien un gimmick on a tous approuvé
les orientations
oui enfin les problèmes
et ça aujourd'hui en 2019 mais il faut
penser à 2022 il réglait les visuels des
demi finales on est là il faut des oui
mais c'est pas celle émanant d'amis non
plus très bien on peut faire des états
généraux je suis très favorable à ces
jeux 10 qui me paraît avant tout
nécessaire c'est qu'ils aient des états
généraux dans chaque hôpitaux dans
chaque hôpital pardon que là
effectivement l'ensemble des personnels
soient écoutés soi et ça c'est une
question de management des hôpitaux
jeudi le le le c'est une communauté tu
le rappelait tout à l'heure c'est une
communauté une communauté c'est un très
beau terme à condition de le vivre et la
communauté ça veut dire que chacun
s'exprime et que chacun s'écoute pour
essayer de trouver à l'échelle de
l'hôpital déjà les mesures certes
certaines de ces mesures dépendront des
deux des décisions nationales
mais on peut faire déjà beaucoup en
terme de jeu dirait d'organisation en
termes de management au niveau l'opt
qu'on a rencontré effectivement un
certain nombre de médecins de personnel
etc
ils nous ont dit leur souffrance parce
que je crois que malheureusement tout le
monde n'est pas aujourd'hui en capacité
d'exercer pleinement ses responsabilités
dans le cadre hospitalier
commençons par changer ça à cette
échelle là laurence cohen moi je
voudrais ajouter des choses quand on dit
ça ne peut pas se faire en un claquement
de doigts ça peut pas se faire en un
jour et c'est bien évidemment personne
autour de la table ne le prétend mais
pardonnez moi de dire que ce sont les
mêmes logiques qui ont été appliqués à
l'hôpital depuis des décennies déjà que
ce soit d'ailleurs je la corde ce
gouvernement actuel comme le précédent
comme celui d'avant ces recettes ne
marche pas pourtant on l'est continue et
on aggrave le déficit de l'hôpital on
aggrave le malaise des personnels c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est toute la
communauté qui le dit moi ce que je
pense intéressant
en plus de répondre à l'urgence c'est
effectivement de construire la santé
avec un complément entre l'hôpital et la
médecine de ville et la médecine de
ville ça veut dire
mais je vais aller attendez je vais
juste aller jusqu'au bout j'en ai pour
30 secondes est ce qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire travailler aussi avec
des mises en lien des mises en réseau
notamment nous ce qu'on porte au niveau
de notre groupe c'est de créer des
centres de santé adossé à l'hôpital qui
travaillent qu'ils puissent être des
relais avec le tiers payant etc tous
toutes ces propositions n'ont l'a pas
votée elle va santé 2022 pourquoi parce
que il ya un refus de prendre ou de
nouveaux financements ou de nouvelles
méthodes et puis management c'est un mot
que je n'aime pas pour l'hôpital parce
que pour moi
l'hôpital n'est pas une entreprise et
madame busin ferait mieux de s'inspirer
de nos propositions de loi les mesures
d'urgence de notre jeu quelques secondes
c'est magnifique on est dans une
organisation syndicale même dans une
organisation agile et mis au jour des
blocages et en linguistique aussi il ya
un mot que j'ai aimé le management
participatif ça me rassurera peut-être
vous voyez le match en deux parties
management de participatif moi c'est un
homme et une de mes passions mais
c'était chaud mais oui jouer juste
redire dire qu'on a voté un plan qui
s'appelle ma centième de nîmes 22 qui va
construire une nouvelle façon d'aborder
l'hôpital salle je ne vous rejoint pas
là quand même des modifications dans la
gestion dont le financement dans les
recettes par rapport à man il ya un vrai
travail entre la médecine de ville la
médecine de proximité et l'hôpital donc
cet ensemble de choses va se construire
mais on ne peut pas demander là on
répond à une urgence c'est vrai mais on
ne répond pas à tous parce que ce n'est
pas aussi de répondre à tous mais pour
bien par ma santé 2022 très bien un mot
pour fonctionner ce que nous avons
quatre parlementaires en plateau un mot
sur la façon tout de même dont le
gouvernement siècle parce que vous avez
quand même tous un peu commencé en
parlant de cela de l'incident la semaine
dernière alors qu emmanuel macron a
annoncé qu'il allait prendre les mesures
pour répondre à la colère du personnel
soignant vous étiez tous en train
d'examiner le budget de la sécurité
sociale c'était quand même un vrai
moment de colère je propose qu'on écoute
c'est bien alain milon et également
monsieur jean louis tourenne un qui
était intervenu à notre micro la semaine
dernière et puis on en discute juste
après c'est
rageant pour les parlementaires que ce
soit l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat
et c'est d'autant plus outrageant pour
nous que mardi soir nous avons fait une
réunion les commissaires de la
commission des affaires sociales tous
partis confondus avec les deux ministres
et que le deux ministres nous ont juré
le coeur sur la main qui ne savait rien
donc nous on nous prend pour des idiots
et eau pour des guignols
nous étions en train d'examiner
l'ensemble du budget sur le financement
de la sécurité sociale
or toutes les informations que nous
avons tous les débats que nous avons
porte sur des éléments faux et on nous
demande de voter un budget qui sera
démentie dans les 2 jours ou trois jours
qui viennent
c'est du jamais vu dans notre république
et par conséquent il est normal que ça
hérisse un peu les parlementaires jean
marie vanlerenberghe on va pas refaire
tout le match cette crispation qui a eu
entre le sénat et l'exécutif pour la
deuxième lecture du budget de la
sécurité sociale est ce que tout ça ça
va bien se passer est ce que les choses
vont être un petit peu touché mes
collègues et moi je suis que rapporteur
général je vais prendre la température
jeudi je souhaite que ça se passe
rapidement on n'est pas obligé de
refaire tous les débats qui ont eu déjà
lieu sur un certain nombre d'articles
tout dépendra effectivement des groupes
politiques de leur volonté de redéposer
les mêmes amendements ou pas je crois
que il faudrait essayer de se concentrer
sur l'essentiel et l'essentiel bas
évidemment c'est l'article 59 l'ondam
mais il ya aussi et fait quelques en
quelques articles que nous n'avons pas
pu a abordé puisque on a ajourné nos
travaux donc je ne suis que moi le
traducteur en quelque sorte de la
volonté de la commission
bernard jeu mais est ce que ça valait
c'est quand même des marques à ce que
vous pensez que la prochaine lecture du
budget de la sécurité sociale qui va
être la lecture finalement la plus
importante va pouvoir bien se dérouler
tant de l'espèce
c'est inquiétant parce que c'est quand
même on parle d'un gouvernement qui
n'arrive pas à présenter le budget
social de la nation dans des termes et
dans des délais qui soient les des
délais normaux beaucoup parlé de
l'hôpital mais sur la question des
retraites par exemple pendant l'examen à
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement a
retiré des dispositifs de son texte dont
sadi un gouvernement qui est en retard
complètement qui est qui est un peu
largué sur ce qu'est la crise
hospitalière qui est un peu largué sur
les questions sociales et qui du coup se
met dans une posture très technique très
technocratique et qui oublient qu'on
fait de la politique et qu'on dirige un
pays mars un lévrier un gouvernement un
peu largué parce que c'est vrai ça fait
quand même vis moi qu'il y a donc la
grève du personnel hospitalier y avait
il vraiment besoin d'attendre concert en
plein examen du budget de la sécu pour
que dire qu'on allait annoncer des
annonçant il ya huit mois de grèves
d'accord il ya on est d'accord là-dessus
15 20 ans de problèmes à l'hôpital de
problèmes qualité dope sans plus grave
bien et aujourd'hui on me dit il fallait
réformer il faut réformer il faut
réformer au moment où on dit oui il y à
encore plus urgence à réformer sur ce
point là nous le faisons et donc nous
l'assumons en tant que responsable
politique
on nous dit hannon fallait pas nous
déranger pendant les travaux excusez moi
il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
est ce qu'on veut peut-être est-ce qu'on
veut aider l'hôpital
est ce qu'on ne veut pas l'aider là on a
décidé jeudi quelque part nous sénateurs
on a été privilégiée puisque les députés
ont dit on veut travailler jusqu'au bout
la fête des couleurs avec humour mais
nous on s'est arrêté avant j'ai proposé
qu'on continue d'ailleurs j'étais le
seul à le proposer qu'on continue
l'étude du plfss jusqu'au bout ça
m'aurait paru plus intelligent puisque
finalement seul l'ondam ce qui est
essentiel mais l'ondam peut être
rectifiées donc l'article 59
on aurait pu continuer ça n'aurait pas
remis en cause 70% de nos travaux et je
trouve ça bien dommage le mot de la fin
leur écoute et moi le jeudi on était en
train d'examiner des amendements jeu
j'ai appris donc les annonces du
président macron j'ai demandé une
suspension de séance parce que je
trouvais comme l'a dit alain milon qu'on
nous prenait part et qu'on nous prenait
pour des imbéciles c'est ma première
roma deuxième remarque le gouvernement
et on a l'impression qu'ils gouvernent à
à vue yb est prise la représentation
parlementaire il méprise les syndicats
et quand la rue bouge
comme elle a bougé pour pour la santé
tout à coup il se réveille et va sortir
quelques mesurettes qui ne font pas le
compte il faut cent mille créations
d'emplois l'hôpital trois cent mille
dans les ehpad en trois ans c'est ça
qu'il faut et j'ai montré très
rapidement que l'argent existe est
maintenant il faut la volonté politique
il faut faire en sorte que effectivement
le patient le soignant soit au coeur du
dispositif de santé c'est parce que
porte ce gouvernement est d'ailleurs il
ya des manifestations qui sont qui sont
annoncés très prochainement le 30
novembre 17 décembre au niveau de la
santé et le 5 décembre avec les
retraites donc là la rue va continuer a
effectivement porté des revendications
très forte ce que le gouvernement va les
entendre on verra bien eh bien on verra
effectivement lors de cette nouvelle
lecture du budget de la sécurité sociale
notamment au sénat merci à tous les
couettes d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci martin lévriers merci jean marie
vanlerenberghe merci bernard genier
merci beaucoup laurence quand même
d'être venu sur ce plateau
autre sujet qui va marquer cette séance
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
les maires qui sont rassemblés toute
cette semaine porte de versailles hier
lors de son discours devant les élus
locaux emmanuel macron a fermé la porte
à l'interdiction des listes
communautaire écoutez bien la réponse de
bruno retailleau le patron des sénateurs
et l'air est à l'origine de cette
proposition
il était ce matin l'invité de public
sénat en l'écoutant emmanuel macron je
l'accuse de refuser le combat contre
l'islamisme qui n'est pas une religion
qui est une idéologie politique qui
s'appuie sur le dévoiement d'une
religion mais il faut le combattre avec
les moyens y compris les moyens que nous
donne la loi
évidemment je prétends pas tout résoudre
mais la république française est soumise
un choix est-ce que nous engageons le
combat avec toutes les armes des armes
républicaines qui sont à notre portée ou
est-ce que nous démissionnons mails
macron propose la démission et de la
démission à la soumission
il n'y a qu'un pas alors qu'en pense le
sénateur socialiste éric kerrouche il
est justement à votre micro alexandre
poussard salle des conférences ans
et oui eric kerrouche est ce que bruno
retailleau a raison de dire qu emmanuel
macron a démissionné face à l'islamisme
politique
moi je pense qu'il faudrait que bruno
retailleau ne démissionne pas par
rapport au pluralisme politique
je pense que ces listes communautaires
sont un problème peut-être mais à brême
qui est périphérique et dont il ne faut
absolument pas faire une centralité
comme c'est le cas actuellement une
crise interdire c'est quand même
peut-être un premier pas de la
république pour lutter contre ce
communautarisme
non mais il ya une question fondamentale
c'est au nom de quoi on les interdirait
il ya un autre principe en france qui
est celui du pluralisme politique et si
on pense qu'en interdisant une formation
politique qui pose des problèmes par
ailleurs si on pense qu'on l'interdise
ans où on trouve des solutions
c'est complètement faux la perspective
elle est complètement différente
il y a trente quarante ans sur ces mêmes
bases
on aurait pu condamner le parti
communiste sur ces mêmes bases on aurait
pu condamner le front national la vraie
question
elle est complètement différente là on
parle de on va dire 50 bureaux de vote
sur de mémoire 69 villes en france où
effectivement cette liste ses listes aux
un petit peu plus de 8 à 10% des
suffrages penser que en simplement
n'interdisant on va limiter le problème
c'est une fausse solution
la réponse ça doit être une réponse
politique doit pas être une réponse
juridique d'interdiction cette réponse
là ne pourra jamais fonctionné parce que
ça n'empêchera pas les idées prospérer
alors on va parler du discours en
général emmanuel macron face au maire
hier au congrès des maires de france il
a essayé d'être bienveillants envers les
édiles de la nation ya quand même des
inquiétudes chez les élus locaux
notamment sur le détricotage à
l'assemblée nationale du projet de loi
engagement et proximité qui avait été
adopté par le sénat
c'est une inquiétude selon vous déjà
emmanuel macron a eu un avantage cet
indice c'est qu'il ya peut-être été
bienveillant mais surtout il a été
présent ce qui n'était pas le cas
l'année dernière donc déjà on peut se
féliciter qu'il ait daigné parler devant
l'ensemble grande majorité de maires
réunis à la porte de versailles sur le
détricotage mais tout est une question
d'interprétation
à vrai dire en ce qui concerne notre
groupe politique socialiste et
républicain nous n'étions pas
fondamentalement en accord avec
l'ensemble des mesures qui avaient été
proposées par le sénat la difficulté
c'est de trouver un équilibre dans le
fonctionnement comme une communauté et
je ne pense pas qu'ils passent par les
compétences mais il passe plutôt par la
démocratisation des intercommunalités et
là on a un équilibre qui est en train de
se dessiner entre l'assemblée et le
sénat avec des points durs de part et
d'autre n'ont finalement ce que fait
l'assemblée c'est plutôt positif
constructif
non je suis pas non plus complètement
d'accord avec ce qui est fait à
l'assemblée nationale b par exemple sur
la compétence économie par exemple sur
la compétence voirie également sur le
rétablissement des compétences
optionnelles je pense que c'est une
bonne chose
l'idée c'est de fonctionner ensemble
c'est pas d'opposer communes et
communautés comme ça a été parfois un
peu le cas lors du texte du sénat très
bien il faut rassembler merci merci
beaucoup et recaro chine a répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
nouvelle réaction alors qu'on le voit
autour de vous il y a de plus en plus de
monde à un quart d'heure de la séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
dans un quart d'heure débute cette
séance d' échanges directs entre les
sénateurs et le gouvernement agit le
plaisir d'accueillir sur ce plateau
denis baranger bonjour vous êtes un
professeur de droit public à
l'université panthéon assas
on vient d'entendre eric kerrouche un
cas à part les à la fois nos de la
question des mères à nous sommes nous en
plein congrès de l'association des
maires de france il a d'abord aussi
intervenue sur bien l'interdiction des
listes communautaire hier et d'un manuel
macron a très clairement fermé la porte
à cette possibilité
vous qu'en pensez-vous sachant que
c'était effectivement la proposition du
patron des sénateurs
bruno retailleau alors on voit
apparaître en france maintenant des
listes communes terres musulmanes elles
peuvent poser un certain problème au
monde politique est ce que faire une loi
pour les interdire est une bonne idée
je ne le pense pas pour deux raisons
d'abord c'est presque certainement
anticonstitutionnelle mais il ne pense
pas que ce soit accepté par le conseil
constitionnel on pourrait changer la
constitution pour faire ça mais on ne
prend pas ce chemin
est-ce que ça serait une bonne idée j'en
suis pas complètement certain il ya
toujours eu des listes confessionnal et
des partis chrétiens en france désormais
des partis musulmans parce qu'une
population
oui c'est très difficile de définir ce
que c'est qu'une liste communautaire et
cela te dirai donc pas d'autres qui plus
est il y aurait danger de ciblage et de
discrimination et puis est ce que ce
serait opportun politiquement et est-ce
que ça qu'on battrait le communautarisme
on peut en douter ça pourrait même
l'encourager donc vous êtes vous y êtes
plutôt défavorable le disait eh bien
emmanuel macron a parlé de ce sujet
alors qu'il était en train d'ouvrir le
congrès des maires de france une grande
réunion annuelle qui se tient
actuellement aux portes de versailles
cela alors que le projet de loi
engagement et proximité est en débat à
l'assemblée nationale à semble qu'ils
étaient en train d'ailleurs de revenir
sur un certain nombre de mesures du
sénat ce qui fait grincer bien des dents
ici
explications de jérôme rabier une
adoption sénatoriale à l'unanimité moins
deux voix des sourires et des formules
de politesse pour saluer un dialogue
fructueux et pourtant un mois après le
vote du projet de loi engagement et
proximité par la chambre haute
le climat n'est plus du tout au beau
fixe entre le sénat et la majorité
gouvernementale sur ce sujet en cause
l'examen en commission des lois à
l'assemblée où les députés sont revenus
sur plusieurs points tel est revenu sur
le transfert facultative de l'eau et
assainissement et surtout sur ce qui est
très attendue par les élus locaux c'est
en fait pas de nouvelle révolution mais
on permet à chacun de s'adapter et de
transférer des compétences à la garde au
congrès des maires de france les
sénateurs ont reçu le soutien de
nombreux maires dans ce bras de fer et
en particulier à la tribune
pourquoi faudrait-il encore
systématiquement en permanence revenir
sur des avancées qui satisfont
la quasi totalité des partenaires mais
pour le ministre en charge des
collectivités territoriales les
ajustements sont mineurs et vista
corriger des mesures mal rédigé ou
financièrement trop coûteuse la
commission des lois a décidé de corriger
ce sont deux choses pour permettre aux
députés dans l'hémicycle de le faire
cette semaine pas plus les députés ne
sont pas venus s'ingérer comme cela dans
la discussion au sénat et dessinateur ne
leur est pas permis donc les deux
chambres vont trouver comme les en ont
l'habitude d'ailleurs la convergence
qu'il va bien les sénateurs réclame à
l'assemblée de revoir sa copie en séance
faute de quoi il ne pourra y avoir
d'accord en commission mixte paritaire
c'est la condition sinequanone d'un
accord en cmp la volonté ça n'est pas
d'avoir un texte à l'eau tiède qui in
fine et ne satisferait pas les élus
locaux la volonté du gouvernement
d'arriver à une application avant le 31
décembre semble désormais s'éloigner
à moins que le sénat au simplement le
ton pour montrer aux maires réunis en
congrès qu'il reste leur meilleur
défenseur dennis baranger voilà un texte
qui a pour objectif essentiel de
satisfaire les maires avant les
municipales
c'est un petit peu éloigné qu'on arrive
à un tel degré de tension supplémentaire
en plein congrès des maires oui et ça va
rendre particulièrement harassante les
questions au gouvernement de cet après
midi on est très largement question va
être largement question de même que du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
c'est une période un petit peu difficile
pour les relations entre l'exécutif d'un
côté le sénat les que l'utilité locales
de l'autre tentait de faire plaisir aux
uns conduit avec ses les autres cette
affaire du projet de loi engagement à
proximité n'est qu'une illustration d'un
problème car actuellement le président
je dirais avec le monde local en général
et aussi avec le monde social avec
l'actualité sociale donc la gestion de
tout ça en même temps n'est pas simple
et ça se passe aujourd'hui au sénat d'où
est-ce que ça remonte pour vous à cette
difficulté entre emmanuel macron et les
élus locaux on a vu
hier que il a tenté de faire de la
câlinothérapie notamment au début de son
discours et pierre on entend aujourd'hui
les retours plus de mères sont
convaincus c'est difficile de faire de
la câlinothérapie
dans une période qui est socialement et
budgétairement aussi tendue est dans une
période où les collectivités locales
sont au centre du problème social on a
vu avec les gilet jaune qui avait une
implantation locale et que le problème
se situer à ce niveau là donc et les
questions sociales nationales sont
devenus aussi des questions locales les
maires sont mis au premier plan au
moment du grand débat national
on leur fait un certain nombre de
promesses ou d'avancé puis le résultat
des courses si je puis dire c'est que
c'est au sénat qu ensuite il ya la
tension et que la position du sénat est
méconnu malmené donc en réalité je pense
que le problème politique et
sociologique de l'exécutif il se joue
aujourd'hui dans les relations avec la
seconde chambre des relations qui
peuvent être effectivement compliqué
parmi les éléments de tension avec les
élus locaux et avec le sénat il ya bien
sûr la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation et le big bang de la
fiscalité locale qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé il ya des manières de françois
baroin qui a interpellé les manuels
macro lui a dit vous avez décidé de
supprimer un impôt qui ne vous
appartient pas il a raison de dire ça
est ce qu'on peut dire ça appartient à
personne il appartient aux contribuables
qui le sur lequel il est prélevé
il appartient aux français pour lesquels
il est dépensé c'est politiquement
compréhensible de la part de monsieur
baroin d'avoir dit ça ya une logique à
ça ce sont les mères c'est le budget des
mères qui sévit sur le budget des mers
messieurs macron a pu répondre que le
jour où on se plaindraient qu'on baisse
les impôts louis où les mères revient
bien de le voir il ya dernier dans les
deux sens il ya quand même un problème
de gestion commune des finances locales
avec la technicité de la question qui
est qui est sous jacente et qui est pas
encore complètement réglé le
gouvernement l'exécutif en général et se
fait quand même assez longtemps n'a pas
dit comment il allait compenser la perte
de cette taxe de coaching promettre une
compensation à l'euro près et en réalité
si ils compensent il va perdre les
avantages qu'il a eue en la retirant cet
axe donc c'est un problème un petit peu
insoluble je comprends assez la position
des maires de là à dire que ça leur
appartient c'est évidemment
techniquement pas vrai c'est parce que
vous me dire monsieur baroin j'ai ma vie
est-ce que ça va être compliqué
d'arriver
un consensus notamment sur le projet de
loi sur le statut de l'élu avant le 1er
janvier 2020 c'était bien ça l'objectif
parce que l'objectif c'est bien sûr les
municipales il ya différents enjeux
locaux
actuellement je pense que l'enjeu local
pour le parti majoritaire la république
en marche cessé d'exister au niveau des
municipales pour un jour existé au
niveau du sénat dans cette attente si je
puis dire la situation sera toujours
difficile elle est difficile
actuellement pour le petit groupe lrm au
sénat il a face à lui un grand groupe à
l'assemblée nationale mais il est
fortement minoritaires on l'a vu avec le
projet de loi de financement de sécurité
sociale qui a été rejetée ce qui est un
geste fort mais partout les sénateurs et
même ceux qui ne venaient pas contre se
sont abstenus même les roms ce sont des
180 par une loi contre amina limité
kazim kazim enlacer sa quasi quasiment
pas de voix pour donc on voit quand même
comment les choses je je dirais se fixe
au niveau du sénat sans solution
évidente ya un problème des relations de
l air un maître monsieur macron avec les
collectivités locales avec la france
rurale et locales en général et c'est au
sénat c'est normalement que le problème
jugé opaque et résoudre mais qui se
posent et va d'ailleurs y avoir une
question sur ce sujet sur l'hôpital qui
va être posée par le président l ère de
la commission des affaires sociales
alain milon justement pour revenir sur
cet épisode avec la semaine dernière
sera quasiment à l'unanimité du budget
de la sécurité sociale que pensez-vous
de la pratique du pouvoir par l'exécutif
actuel on a beaucoup entendu la semaine
dernière les parlementaires qui disent
pas tout simplement nous oublie c'est un
théâtre d'ombrés disait par exemple
bruno retailleau ils pourront parler de
mépris là encore on peut les comprendre
ça fait depuis je crois le 10 novembre
que monsieur milon a dit il va y avoir
un problème si les annonces que promet
les annonces qu'annonce si je puis dire
le gouvernement et le président en
matière de pi talent se concrétise par
des mesures ça n'est pas dans le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale que nous discutons actuellement
donc le 10 novembre c'était déjà il ya
maintenant 15 à peu près 15 jours
aujourd'hui la situation est très tendue
puisque il ya un rejet du plfss du
projet de loi de financement de sécurité
sociale par cette majorité de sénateurs
qu'on vient de voir ses très rares c'est
arrivé en 2017 sur un texte de mai
hollande mais sinon ça c'est 23 ans je
crois que ce n'était pas arrivé s'est
pas non plus définitif puisque on sait
qu'il ya eu des rejets de départir set
roger partiel et un rejet de l'ensemble
je crois que c'est quand même assez
et puis jamais comment dire de façon
aussi inattendue jamais parce qu'il y
avait eu un événement leur soudain de
l'exécutif il ya un air s'immiscer dans
le texte tout est fait il ya un décalage
de calendrier
monsieur macron à son calendrier lui il
l'a fait changer par le changement de sa
pratique de président avant ils
voulaient se situer à distance
on va arriver christophe castaner 1 le
ministre de l'intérieur salle des
conférences alors que nous sommes à cinq
minutes du début de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement je
vous laisse poursuivre au lieu d'être un
président qui restent à distance au
dessus des problèmes il a décidé de se
placer dans le terrain même de l'action
par son discours d'epernay
résultat des courses son annonce parce
que c'est lui qui l'a fait en l'occasion
elle se place dans un comment dirais-je
d'un calendrier parlementaire qui est
inadaptée puisqu'il ya un projet de loi
qui ne contient pas
ces annonces qui peut pas les contenir
tout de suite il était assez logique que
le sénat je sais pas s'il devait rejeter
le texte qu'est ce qu'ils allaient faire
attendre des amendements gouvernementaux
en cours de procédure ce qui est
toujours assez malencontreux attendu
mais qu'il ne serait pas arrivé radiall
et henri maire a pas eu le temps
d'arriver
fatalement il ya eu la cmp je crois à la
commission mixte paritaire c'est à dire
la discussion entre l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat qui a eu lieu hier
et si je ne me trompe pas qui ne pouvait
échoir j'ai en tout cas qui ne pouvait
qu'apporter donc le texte va
probablement revenir devant le sénat je
crois que ce sera vers le 25 ou le 30
novembre
il n'a pas le temps de discuter le sénat
on va devoir refondre le calendrier du
sénat et de toute façon avec de fortes
chances que le sénat ne souhaite
toujours pas content du contenu de ce
projet de loi que l'assemblée nationale
ait le dernier mot
c'est une situation impossible je
voudrais pas non plus exagérer la crise
institutionnelle les sénateurs lors un
petit peu fait monter en mayonnaise
aussi de manière à faire à faire
apparaître un problème politique qui lui
est elle apprend la main le problème
politique c'est aussi est-ce que c'est
aussi qu' aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup le
face à face entre emmanuel macron et les
citoyens on a beaucoup entendu que les
corps intermédiaires ne trouvaient plus
leur place
dans cette organisation il ya une
majorité en france il n'y a pas vraiment
d'opposition significative dans une
situation comme celle-là on constate
l'absence de contre-pouvoir ou de
contrepartie efficace dire que pour le
moment il n'y a pas véritablement de
grands représentants de l'opposition qui
peut parler compte monsieur mâcon en
réalité ça ne facilite pas la tâche ni
de monsieur ma chronique son
gouvernement ni de sa majorité parce
qu'ils ont personne avec qui parlait
personne à qui s'opposent et ils ont les
gilet jaune
ils ont des français souvent de communes
rurales qui sont de plus en plus
mécontents et qu'ils le disent avec une
certaine virulence
ça va être le rôle du sénat d'être ce
contre-pouvoir ça tombe bien c'est c'est
le nom du dernier livre titre du dernier
livre de monsieur gérard larcher donc il
est conscient de l'opportunité politique
qui la sépare un jour voir aimé voir
s'il est plus premier ministre hun sen
est attendu il est attendu monsieur d'un
philippe parce que l'homme monsieur
macron a dit de lui qu'il attendait la
réalisation technique du projet sur
l'hôpital et de réformes sur l'hôpital
donc les réponses du premier ministre
sont particulièrement attendus
aujourd'hui bien merci beaucoup dany
baranger pour cet éclairage ajustements
nous allons rejoindre toujours sur cette
thématique de l'hôpital alexandre
poussard car vous êtes avec alain milon
le président l ère de la commission des
affaires sociales et oui alors milon
vous allez interroger le gouvernement
sur ce plan d'urgence en faveur de
l'hôpital
est ce que vous allez adressé un message
de satisfaction pour gouvernement je
vous étonnerai fort si je vous disais
oui non certainement pas l'hôpital est
en grave danger tout le monde le sait on
s'en rend pas compte
on s'en rend compte depuis d'ailleurs
plusieurs années pas depuis plusieurs
mois depuis plusieurs années il est en
danger à la suite de la mise en place
des 35 heures
non compensés par des financements
supplémentaires pour des postes
supplémentaires à la suite d'un mise en
place de la loi hpst dans certains
domaines en particulier l'écartement
des professionnels de santé du processus
de décision et des politiques du
processus de décision
il est mise en place depuis les oies
touraine et wegmann butin qui sont en
fait des lois d'organisation du travail
des professionnels entre eux mais pas
des lois qui apporte des financements
supplémentaires et évidemment mises en
place par la t2a et surtout par les
honda hm successifs qui était hyper
restrictif par rapport au budget des
hôpitaux
donc finalement dans cette situation
catastrophique de l'hôpital ya une
responsabilité des gouvernements
précédents et notamment de la droite il
ya une responsabilité de tous les
gouvernements précédents depuis plus
d'une vingtaine d'années où est tout à
fait mais là encore une fois notamment
la droite oui pourquoi pas c'est vrai de
hpst en particulier la loi bachelot à la
loi bachelot mais aussi et surtout les
35 heures et la loi bachelot est arrivée
après les difficultés mises en place par
les 35 heures sur les dans les hôpitaux
très bien cette rallonge budgétaire elle
est suffisante
on dit que les hôpitaux ont un
endettement de près de 30 milliards
la longe budgétaire qui est proposé est
de un milliard cinq dans le cadre de
l'ondam ouais c'est pas dans le cadre
évidemment des hôpitaux uniquement et
pour les hôpitaux mais un milliard cinq
sur trois ans on demande donc à
l'ensemble du système de santé de fer 4
milliards d'économies par an 4 milliards
sur trois ans a fait 12 milliard un
milliard cinq de retirer il reste quand
même 10 milliards 5,2 nécessité de faire
des restrictions traversé beaucoup très
bien donc ce n'est pas suffisant vu
qu'on va écouter votre question dans
l'hémicycle du sénat et on va retrouver
quand un chalmé qui en tribune de presse
de l'hémicycle
quant à cette saison ça va être marquée
par le plan d'urgence pour l'hôpital oui
tout à fait avec la question du
président alain milon que vous venez
d'évoquer avec lui également deux autres
questions sur ce plan hôpital dévoilé ce
midi par edouard philippe et par agnès
buzyn avec effectivement on vers un
edouard philippe qui pourra s'expliquer
sur les détails de ce plan autre moment
fort avec l'actualité des maires de
france le congrès qui se tient en ce
moment à paris
trois questions au total sur ces
questions autour des mères
et vous pourrez les voir il y aura une
prochaine prise de parole notamment sur
l'épineux problème des finances locales
une autre prise de parole est très
attendue celle de philippe bas le
président de la commission des lois qui
doit également posé une question sur le
congrès des maires
après la prise de parole du ponant un
public sur le sujet la toute première
question à suivront dans l'hémicycle
dans un instant c'est celle d'un
sénateur de haute garonne pierre
médevielle il va parler la sécurité des
ponts en france 48 heures après la chute
d'un ouvrage d'art dans une rivière
rivière tarn
un accident qui a causé je vous le
rappelle deux morts des morts suite
notamment au point de ce poids lourd qui
s'est engagé sur le pont et d'autres
questions à que ce soit les retraites la
réforme de la pac les droits de l'enfant
les intempéries dans la drôme beaucoup
de sujets a évoqué jeudi dans
l'hémicycle alors que et bien le silence
se fait dans les travées derrière moi
dans l'hémicycle bientôt à la séance est
correct et d'activités va se faire on a
vu le gouvernement au grand complet
arrivé au tour d'edouard philippe dans
l'hémicycle on verra aussi ce bras de
fer qui s'instaure entre l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat sur le projet de
loi engagement et proximité vous savez
ce projet de loi qui doit répondre aux
blues des mères vous allez le voir les
sénateurs
eh bien ils dénoncent le fait que
l'assemblée nationale détricote le texte
qui a déjà été adopté par la chambre
haute du parlement et le président
gérard larcher est même fixer des lignes
rouges aux députés sans quoi il n'y
aurait pas d'accord en commission mixte
paritaire sur ce projet de loi
on va voir tout ça avec elle la séance
des collectivités qui commence
maintenant
ou pas reçu d'observation il n'y en a
pas en séance il est donc adoptée sous
les réserves d'usagé informe le sénat
que la commission mixte paritaire
chargée d'élaborer un texte sur le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
en 2019 est parvenu à l'adoption d'un
texte commun
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat sur le pré site
internet
chacun fera attention respect du temps
et bien sûr au respect des uns et des
autres la parole est maintenant notre
collègue pierre médevielle pour le
groupe de l'union centriste vous avez la
parole mon cher collègue monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues un pont s'est effondré lundi à
méré poids sur temps dans mon
département
mes premières pensées auxquelles
j'associe mes collègues de haute garonne
vont bien évidemment aux familles des
deux victimes de ce drame
l'heure n'est pas aux polémiques il est
trop tôt pour incriminer qui que ce soit
même circonstances de cet accident sont
maintenant connus triste coïncidence
ce drame intervient six mois juste après
la publication du rapport de la mission
d'information sur la sécurité dépend du
président hervé morin
notre pays compte plus de 200 millions
dont 90% sont gérés par les
collectivités locales
vingt-cinq mille d'entre eux sont déjà
répertoriés comme étant mauvais état
contractuels la situation est
particulièrement inquiétante pour les
100000 pompe qui relève des communes et
des intercommunalités
elles n'ont pas l'algérie ni les moyens
d'assurer le diagnostic la surveillance
il ne remise à niveau quand cela est
nécessaire
à l'heure du congrès des maires de
collectivités s'interrogent sur leur
source et ont absolument besoin des deux
ce rapport très pertinent préconise de
mettre en oeuvre un véritable plan
marshall pour les ponts en créant un
fonds d aide aux collectivités comme on
l'a fait pour les tunnels après la
catastrophe du mont blanc avec la mise
en place de moyens importants pour le
sécuriser
il faut aujourd'hui débloquer des
crédits pour remettre en état les
pauvres monsieur le ministre
s'agissant des ponts géré par l'état la
loi prévoit une augmentation des moyens
dédiés à leur entretien qui n'est
toutefois pas suffisamment rapides par
rapport aux besoins estimés à quand un
accompagnement adapté
urgent et nécessaire pour les communes
et les intercommunalités qui n'ont pas
les moyens financiers techniques et
humains leur permettant d'assurer seules
la sécurité de ces ouvrages pour vous
répondre la parole et secrétaire d'état
en charge le prof sports jean baptiste
de djebbari monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous avez rappelé le drame
survenu avant-hier matin à mirepoix sur
tarn et je veux moi aussi avoir une
pensée pour les victimes et leurs
familles pour les services de secours
qui se sont mobilisés très tôt et pour
certains des témoins qui ont eu le
courage de porter assistance aux
personnes à l'heure en péril vous savez
qu'une enquête judiciaire est en cours
et j'ai diligenté le bureau d'enquêtés
et accidents des transports terrestres
pour tirer toutes les conclusions
technique sur cet accident et sans
présenter ce que pourront dire ces
enquêtes il semble qu'un poids lourd qui
a emprunté le pont ce matin la dépasser
très largement le tonnage de 19 tonnes
autorisées par ce pont ce pont avait été
inspectée par le serena en 2010 est sans
défaut apparent et une inspection en
2018 avait confirmé cette ce diagnostic
une expulsion diligentée par les
services départementaux
je tiens à répondre à votre à la seconde
partie de votre question sur les moyens
engagés et j'ai eu ici ce débat il ya
quelques semaines sur la sécurité dépend
ensuite aux rapports qui avait commis
monsieur dagobert et monsieur moret j'ai
rappelé l'engagement du gouvernement
inscrit dans la loi d'orientation des
mobilités d'augmenter de façon très
significative les budgets sur les ponts
c'est effectivement 70 millions en 2019
et plus de 120 millions en 2026 qui
permettent d'avoir ou d'accéder à cette
sécurité si nécessaire
s'agissant des ponts de rétablissement
suite à la loi didier vous savez qu'un
recensement est en cours et qu'il
ouvrira droit à cofinancement dès lors
que ce recensement sera complet d'ici à
la fin d'année
enfin l'état les services de l'état elle
sert et massot tout à fait disponible
pour apporter l'un pu en ingénierie et
je partage l'ambition notamment de
monsieur dagobert est mort est d'avoir
accès très rapidement un carnet de santé
de l'ensemble des ponts et 2 est doté de
capteurs qui permettent de surveiller
leur état en temps réel sur ce sujet
monsieur le sénateur sous les assurés
de la mobilisation de l'état et du
partage de votre ambition sur le sujet
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur mais
deviennent pour quelques secondes que
sur le ministre blanc l'accident est une
chose
par contre les sommes alloués à
l'entretien que ce soit des pommes des
routes eau des voies ferrées sont
insuffisantes on ne veut pas regarder
nos infrastructures se regarder
passivement
on ne peut plus jouer de la sécurité de
nos concitoyens merci la parole est à
notre collègue bernard cazeau pour le
groupe de la république en marche
il avait la parole monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame ministre des solidarités de la
santé aujourd'hui madame l'hôpital est
malade mais il est vrai que ça vient de
loin celui ci n'a pas supporté les
évolutions successives qui lui ont été
infligées depuis plusieurs années tant
sur le plan financier corvette
qu'organisationnel sans parler de
l'exercice médical de ville qui a
beaucoup évolué depuis vingt ans et dont
la pratique est à mon avis en partie
responsable de l'engorgement des
urgences le malaise hospitalier est
arrivé à son apogée avec il ya quelques
jours une manifestation réunissant
praticiens et personnels hospitaliers de
façon assez massive
devant cette situation en conférence de
presse ce matin monsieur le premier
ministre et vous même avez apporté une
réponse forte concrètes et rapidement
applicables qui permet de répondre à
l'urgence et qui s'articule autour d'une
accélération de la stratégie
ma santé 2022 et donne suite aux
demandes des professionnels sentir à
travers trois mesures phares un
abondement de 1,5 milliard d'euros sur
trois ans pour l'hôpital les canons dame
hospitalier c'est important qu'ils
passent à 2 4% permettant une vision
pluriannuelle une reprise de la dette de
l'hôpital d'un tiers soit 10 milliards
d'euros
un renforcement de l'activité des
hôpitaux et plusieurs mesures telles que
la prime annuelle de 800 euros nets pour
les personnels hospitaliers des secteurs
sous tension
une valorisation financière des équipes
engagées d'environ 300 euros ou encore
une revalorisation des métiers des deux
soignantes
madame la ministre nous avons vécu ces
trente dernières années plusieurs
réformes hospitalières elles ont eu des
conséquences diverses parfois obscurs
parfois obstrue mal parfois des
sculptures s'il vous plaît à aucune
seconde question
ma question est la suivante si je peux
parler
en quoi les décisions prises par le
gouvernement nous permettent d'espérer
que demain l'hôpital va jouer le rôle
fondamental qu'attendent les français
on vous répond la parole est à la
ministre des solidarités et de la
chanter madame agnès buzyn madame la
ministre
mais si monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bernard cazeau vous avez raison
la crise de l'hôpital public est une
crise très ancienne elle connaît depuis
quelques semaines une de ces phases les
plus aigus et après des années de statu
quo et malgré l'augmentation des crédits
à l'hôpital que nous avions voté avant
que vous aviez voté l'année dernière il
nous a fallu prendre la mesure de cette
crise légitime et surtout de proposer
des solutions nouvelles qui répondent
aux attentes
transformer le système de soins c'était
l'objectif de ma santé 2022 et nous
avons engagé cette réforme afin de
replacer le patient au coeur du système
de privilégier la qualité des soins
plutôt que des logiques comptables
ce plan visait à réorganiser la médecine
de ville et un réarmer les hôpitaux de
proximité pour assurer la continuité des
soins pour nos concitoyens
c'est également le sens du pacte de
refondation d urgence qui vise à éviter
des passages aux urgences
inutile en orientant les patients qui
peuvent être pris en charge
ailleurs c'est enfin la suppression du
numerus clausus qu est la réforme des
études de médecine qui vise enfin à
pouvoir bénéficier dans les années qui
viennent d'un peu plus de médecins ces
réformes tout le savon elles prendront
du temps pour produire tous leurs effets
et c'est essentiel
il y a il faut le reconnaître il ya un
consensus partagé sur les orientations
de ma santé 2022 pour autant l'hôpital
public aujourd'hui nécessite des mesures
d'urgence les annonces présentées ce
matin s'inscrivent dans la logique du
plan ma santé 2022 et elles répondent à
trois objectifs 1 d'abord restaurer
l'attractivité de l'hôpital public
notamment en redonnant envie aux
professionnels de s'engager dans ce
secteur public d'y construire une
carrière et de récompenser l'engagement
des professionnels sap réforme vise
aussi à assouplir le fonctionnement des
hôpitaux en faisant confiance aux
responsables de terrain et en facilitant
les prises de décision et enfin la
réforme présentée par le premier
ministre vise à redonner des moyens
considérables à l'opie à l'hôpital
immédiatement par une augmentation des
budgets et dans la durée avec un
allègement significatif de la dette des
hôpitaux
je préciserai les mesures dans les
questions suivantes je vous remercie
monsieur la parole est à notre collègue
éric jean ça mais tu as pour le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
vous avez la parole merci merci monsieur
le président monsieur premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres ma
question s'adresse mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales madame la ministre
le congrès des maires de france est
ouvert hier au moment où à l'assemblée
nationale débute la discussion du projet
de loi relatifs à l'engagement dans la
vie locale et à la proximité et à la
proximité de l'action publique pardon ce
texte que le sénat a adopté à
l'unanimité moins deux voix vise à
remettre le maire au centre de la
gouvernance locale alors que de nombreux
élus font part de leur désarroi et
certains sondages indiquent même que
seul un maire sur deux envisagerait de
se représenter
nous ne dirons jamais assez à quel point
le mandat de maire constituent la
quintessence de la vie démocratique
le coeur battant de notre république le
président de la république l'a
d'ailleurs rappelé hier dans son hommage
aux maires de france
vous le savez bien madame la ministre le
sénat a beaucoup travaillé pour aboutir
à un texte d' équilibre dans votre
collègue sébastien lecornu qui était en
charge des débats s'est d'ailleurs
félicité c'est donc avec une certaine
circonspection 12 et féminisme que nous
avons pris connaissance du texte de la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale un texte qui marque pour nous
un recul par rapport à notre vote par
exemple sur la compétence eau et
assainissement sur l'assouplissement de
l'intercommunalité sur l'indemnité des
élus sur la territorialisation des
compétences intercommunales facultative
monsieur le corps nu l'a dit lui même
l'une des ambitions de ce texte que vous
avez vous lu coproduire avec le sénat
est de répondre au sentiment de
dépossession des élus en particulier
face à la complexité normative
c'est ce que notre assemblée a souhaité
faire en introduisant davantage de
proximité et de souplesse dans la
gouvernance des collectivités en
remettant la commune au coeur du pacte
républicain pour redonner du sens du
contenu de l'attrait et des moyens au
mandat de maire dans ce contexte ma
question est donc la suivante comment
voyez-vous la convergence entre la
vision de nos deux assemblées pour
parvenir à un compromis pour vous
répondre la parole et à madame la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales dame jacqueline gourault
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur effectivement le gouvernement a
proposé un projet de loi engagement et
proximité que le ministre sébastien
lecornu a construit avec l'ensemble des
élus
que ce soit les députés les sénateurs et
les associations d'élus
vous avez eu bien sûr un texte qui a été
voté à l'unanimité
c'est normal c'était le texte du sénat
qui je vous le rappelle est sorti mais
c'est normal c'est votre rôle vous êtes
des parlementaires mais vous êtes des
parlementaires et les députés sont des
parlementaires et les députés mais les
députés commencent à légiférer
le bic serait pas dans cet hémicycle
qu'on va ne pas reconnaître le rôle du
bicamérisme
et donc je vais prendre je vais prendre
trois exemples monsieur le député pour
que les choses soient claires d'ailleurs
monsieur le sénateur pardon excusez moi
oui
[Applaudissements]
ça n'est pas une provocation monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur en ce qui concerne
ce que vous avez voté au sénat
concernant les compétences facultatives
et notamment ce que mathieu darnaud
appel l'intercommunalité à la carte
nous avons respecté ou l'assemblée
nationale à respecter le texte
simplement en leur écrivant simplement
pour une affaire législatif plus précise
deuxième point sur les indemnités je
prends trois exemples sur les indemnités
nous reprenons l'idée aussi de
l'amendement de mathieu darnaud du sénat
troisièmement sur l'eau et
l'assainissement
je me permets de rappeler qu'à la suite
de la loi de notre la compétence eau et
assainissement était obligatoire en 2020
que c'est ce gouvernement qui a reporté
en 2026 avec les minorités de blocage et
que nous assouplissons encore dans cette
loi inclure avec la possibilité de les
négations le rôle de l'eau et
l'assainissement pour les eaux connues
je crois que c'est un grand progrès et
que nous avons entendu le sénat merci
madame la glisse
la parole est à deux trucs que la
guillaume gontard pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste de la parole merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
depuis des mois que couvre la crise de
l'hôpital on aurait pu imaginer que la
loi santé ou le budget de la sécurité
sociale associe le parlement à leur
recherche de solutions on aurait pu
aussi imaginer une concertation des
partenaires sociaux voire pourquoi pas
un grenelle de l'hôpital rien de tout
cela
votre mépris du parlement et des corps
intermédiaires n'est pas nouveau mais sa
violence continue de nous heurter
il ya un an votre méthode était
exactement la même pour répondre au
gilet jaune vous ne réagisse et que
quand la colère sociale vient enrayer la
mécanique de votre machine nil aux néo
libérale qui broie jour après jour le
service public
après avoir minimisé les problèmes après
avoir louvoyé ils vous aura fallu plus
de huit mois de mouvement social pour
commencer à mesurer la gravité de la
situation mais comme d'habitude vous
fait le service minimum
vous reprenez une partie de la dette
c'était indispensable
on rappellera que ce sont les règles
européennes qui oblige les hôpitaux à se
financer auprès des banques privées
une aberration pour revaloriser les
salaires pour embaucher pour soulager
les personnels et éviter les fermetures
de lits le monde hospitalier vous
demande de doubler l'objectif national
de dépenses de l'assurance maladie soit
4 à 5 milliards d'euros par an vous
proposez dix fois moins sur les
augmentations de salaires rien sur
l'ouverture de lits rien sur les
embauches rien sur les internes
rien non plus ce que vous concédez d'une
main avec des primes insuffisante pour
certaines catégories de personnel
seulement vous le reprendre et demain
avec la réforme des retraites
nous ne pouvons donc pas imaginer que
votre réponse soit exhaustive
monsieur le premier ministre merci de
nous préciser les autres mesures que
vous envisagez pour répondre à la crise
hospitalière merci vous répondre la
parole est à madame la ministre des
solidarités et de la santé madame agnès
buzyn madame la mini
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs des sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gotha la situation que vous
décrivez nous ne l'avons pas créer nous
l'avons reçue en héritage vous le savez
vous connaissez mon engagement total en
faveur de l'hôpital public
les propositions nous avons annoncé avec
monsieur le premier ministre ce matin
sont très concrètes
elles sont le fruit d'années
d'expérience de terrain elles sont le
fruit des conférences des directeurs
d'hôpitaux des conférences des
présidents des commissions médicales
d'établissement elles sont issues des
syndicats et donc elles ont été
concertées nous ne nous donnons au
personnel de l'hôpital aux soignants aux
médecins aux paramédicaux des moyens et
des primes qu'ils reconnaissent leur
engagement permanent dans le soin des
patients des personnels mieux traiter
des conditions de travail améliorées
ce sont des patients mieux accueilli
mieux soignés dans des lieux plus adapté
nous devons également à chaque hôpital
de la marge de manoeuvre financière et
ils le demandaient nous dégageons 1,5
milliard d'euros sur trois ans et du
budget supplémentaire pour recruter pour
moderniser pour ouvrir des lits là où il
en faut les établissements auront
l'autonomie pour investir parce que nous
la leur de nom mais aussi parce que nous
allons les soulager financièrement du
poids de leurs dettes d'un tiers de la
dette des hôpitaux soit 10 milliards
d'euros sur trois ans enfin nous nous
sommes engagés à ce que les tarifs des
hôpitaux
c'est à dire les prix que les hôpitaux
facturent à l'assurance maladie et qui
représentent une grande partie de leur
budget et bien que ces tarifs non
seulement ne baisseront plus
contrairement à ceux ci à ce qui s'est
passé
jusqu'en 2018 mais ils augmenteront
pendant trois ans ils auront cette
visibilité et ils seront revus encore à
la hausse à chaque fois que la lutte
contre les actes inutiles permettront
aux hôpitaux de faire des économies tout
cela sera rendu aux établissements de
santé
je les dis je le répète je veux que les
hôpitaux bénéficient directement de
toutes les autonomies réalisé par une
meilleure programmation des soins et
meilleure pertinence des soins tout cela
nous le devons aux hospitaliers
ils attendaient ces annonces elles sont
à la hauteur de leurs espérances je vous
remercie monsieur compteur il faut
arrêter de parler d'héritage on veut des
actes nos concitoyens veulent des actes
et des actes tout de suite si vous
n'êtes pas en mesure d'ouvrir les yeux
alors les retraités les chômeurs les
précaires les étudiants les pompiers les
personnels de santé les cheminots les
gilet jaune et tout le peuple que vous
mettez à l'agonie finiront par vous les
ouvrir l'hiver social arrive et il sera
rude
la parole est à notre collègue alain
durand pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les minimes sur le premier ministre mes
chers collègues
madame la secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie évoqué le 5
novembre dernier la volonté du
gouvernement d'engager une réforme des
impôts de production accuse le site de
grever les finances des entreprises
une idée probablement soufflé par le
medef et qui résonne de plus en plus au
sein de votre ministère
or dans ce panier d'impôts on retrouve
la cvae qui pèse 18 milliards d'euros la
cfe qui en baisse de 7 des impôts locaux
perçus par les régions les départements
les opci où les communes après la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
et plus près de nous le tour de
passe-passe de la taxe d'habitation
c'est tout simplement la
décentralisation que vous continuez de
détricoter ce coup de canif fiscale
économique ne sera ni fait qu'aggraver
l'autonomie fiscale de nos collectivités
et par voie de conséquence à faiblir et
les services aux usagers
en effet ce sont les élus locaux qui
jour après jour doivent répondre aux
attentes légitimes de leurs administrés
ce sont les élus locaux qui oeuvrent
jour après jour pour garantir le
développement harmonieux et solidaire
d'un village d'une ville d'un
département d'une région
tout simplement pour construire une
république des territoires plus juste à
l'heure des mouvements sociaux gilet
jaune étudiants blouses blanches
policiers agriculteurs enseignants au
moment où la république aurait plutôt
besoin de se rassembler vous ne trouvez
rien de mieux que de poursuivre cette
entreprise de démolition de la fiscalité
locale en mettant cette fois ci la cfe
et la cvae dans votre viseur
dans une démocratie nous le savons tous
l'impôt est un lien de citoyenneté il
est donc de notre responsabilité de lui
redonner toute sa légitimité en veillant
à ce qu'ils soient répartis
équitablement dans le respect de la
justice sociale et ce n'est pas en le
supprimant monsieur le ministre que vous
apporterez plus les quitter
la question est simple les maires sont
réunis à ce moment qu'un congrès porte
de versailles
pouvez-vous leur affirmer que cette
petite musique qui consisterait à
inscrire dans une trajectoire de baisse
la cfe et la cvae 25 s'arrêter de jouer
pour vous répondre la parole est aux
jeux kkr d'état auprès du ministre de
l'action des comptes publics
monsieur olivier du shop monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs destinataire
monsieur le sénateur durant votre
question évoque plusieurs aspects de la
fiscalité locale et permettez-moi de
revenir sur deux d'entre eux premier
point pour homme et je saisis moi aussi
l'occasion du congrès des maires
garantir comme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le faire et comme le premier ministre
l'a fait à plusieurs reprises garantir à
l'ensemble des élus de france que la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation qui
est avant tout une mesure de justice
fiscale pouvoir d'achat pour nos
compatriotes sera intégralement
compensée aux collectivité
non pas par des dotations comme ça a
toujours été le cas mais par des
recettes fiscales dynamique pérenne à
l'euro près de manière à ce que
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
soit assurée de manière à ce que l'on ne
reproduisent pas les travers du fonds
national de garantie individuelle des
ressources qui avait été mise en place à
l'occasion de la suppression la taxe
professionnelle de manière aussi parce
que les collectivités ne connaissent pas
à nouveau comme ça toujours été le cas
un amoindrissement des allocations de
compensation que l'état un moment ou un
autre cesse de verser nous changeons
modèle nous en sorte que la compensation
soit intégrale qu'elle soit durable et
surtout qu'elles soient dynamiques et je
pense que nous pourrons les uns et les
autres nous accorder sur ce sujet là
vous avez ensuite évoqué la question de
la fiscalité sur les entreprises
je voudrais d'abord souligner que
lorsque l'on réfléchit le selon
réfléchir un peu de productions et agnès
manière une hache et ma collègue en
témoignerait tout aussi fortement
nous pourrons aussi penser à d'autres
impôts notamment la c3s considéré comme
un pot particulièrement lourd presque 4
milliards d'euros est considéré aussi
par le conseil d'analysé économique
comme un impôt partie
herman inefficace et qui doit être
réformé nous pouvons aussi rouvrir un
certain nombre de chantiers sans
nécessairement poser la question du
niveau des ressources
est-ce que les barèmes de ces feux sont
toujours satisfaisant pour les élus je
ne crois pas est-ce que les recettes de
cvae sont toujours prévisibles pour les
collectivités ça n'est pas le cas non
plus toutes celles et ceux qui ont une
expérience intercommunal ont pu le
mesurer
est-ce que l'on peut progresser comme ça
a été le cas avec la révision des
valeurs locatives des locaux
professionnels oui il faut continuer ce
travail de sincères isation nous avons
un objectif faire en sorte que le panier
fiscal sur lequel s'appuient les
collectivités sont instables qu'ils
soient justes et qu'il soit durable
merci
la parole est qu à notre collègue
colette mélot pour le groupe des
indépendants
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres monsieur le ministre chers
collègues nous célébrons aujourd'hui le
30e anniversaire de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
ratifiée par 191 pays dont la france
cette journée est également marquée par
la mobilisation nationale des
accompagnants d'élèves en situation de
handicap
l'école de la confiance en favoriser la
valorisation de leur statut en
transformant les contrats aidés en cdd
de trois ans 4500 postes supplémentaires
ont été déployés portant le nombre
d'accompagnants à 90 milles nous savons
que le taux de scolarisation de ses
enfants s'est considérablement améliorée
en deux ans quarante mille enfants
supplémentaires ont été accueillis en
milieu scolaire ordinaire portant ses
effectifs à 361 1500 en dépit de ces
avancées que nous saluons la
scolarisation des enfants handicapés
reste un défi pour le gouvernement et un
problème quotidien pour les familles
sans solution les associations
témoignent du fossé entre les annonces
et la réalité il serait onze mille
enfants à ne pouvoir bénéficier de
l'accompagnement nécessaires faute de
moyens déployés et faute d'attractivité
du métier d'accompagnant le président de
la république a fait de la scolarisation
des élèves en situation de handicap une
priorité du quinquennat le gouvernement
se donne trois ans pour bâtir le socle
de l'école inclusive et assurer à chaque
élève un égal accès à l'éducation selon
ses besoins particuliers
monsieur le ministre à l'heure de la
mobilisation nationale d
compagne en d'élèves en situation de
handicap quelle réponse d'urgence
proposez-vous aux onze mille élèves sans
solution quelles actions pour améliorer
concrètement les conditions de travail
des avs h qui n'ont pas tous bénéficié
des mesures annoncées
merci vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
monsieur attal vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs joe pris d'abord
d'excuser l'absence de jean-michel
blanquer requis est actuellement au
congrès des maires pour échanger sur les
questions d'éducation d'une manière
générale est évidemment cette question
de l'école inclusive va venir dans les
débats parce qu'elle est au coeur des
attentes des français au coeur du
quotidien des français qui évidemment
sollicite énormément leurs élus pour
aborder ces questions là avec une
réalité c'est que nous sommes en train
de rattraper un retard très important
sur cette question-là de l'école
inclusive que les besoins étaient très
important qu'il reste important qu'une
partie du chemin a été parcourue qu'il
en reste
mais la conviction que nous avons c'est
qu'en cette rentrée 2010 9 nous avons
franchi un pas très important à pas de
géant pour l'école inclusive vous avez
rappelé les chiffres
quarante mille élèves accueillis en plus
depuis deux ans un renforcement très
fort 300 créations du lys cette année
des classes autisme 4500 recrutement
d'un e s h pour accueillir accompagner
davantage d'enfants en situation de
handicap à l'école donc des progrès très
important vous poser deux questions très
concrètes à la fin de votre question
d'abord les élèves qui aujourd'hui n'ont
pas encore de solutions d'accompagnement
eux
nous agissons pour les aider pour les
accompagner j'ai dit qu'il restait des
progrès à faire ne sont plus en 2000
mais aujourd'hui 8000 ça reste beaucoup
c'est deux fois moins que l'année
dernière à la même époque et pour les
accompagner
nous avons renforcé dans un certain
nombre de mdph le détachement de
personnel enseignant pour traiter les
dossiers en urgence d'ici à la fin de
l'année et donc régler ces situations
d'ici à la fin de l'année la deuxième
question de vous poser est celle des
accompagnants des aes h
nous avons agi en cette rentrée pour
déprécariser leur statut avec des
contrats plus robustes au moins 3 ans en
cdi
même des contrats aidés qui sont moins
nombreux pour déprécariser cette
profession pour mieux les former mieux
les accompagner financièrement
aujourd'hui nous sommes à plus de 80%
des tâches qui ne sont plus en emplois
aidés qui sont en contrat de trois ans
ou plus ou cdi
il en reste à couvrir et ça sera la
mobilisation des années qui viennent
avec pour objectif d'avoir des contrats
robuste pour l'ensemble des
accompagnants d'ici à la fin du
quinquennat
je vous remercie madame bello merci
monsieur le ministre c'est à la fois un
sujet sensible et compliqué beaucoup de
familles concernées sont dans la
détresse et attendent des mesures si
elles ne sont immédiates très rapide
merci la parole est maintenant aux
présidents philippe bas pour le groupe
l'est républicain
monsieur le président je vous remercie
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre
hier le président de la république a été
reçue par les maires dans le meilleur
esprit républicain
il leur a rendu hommage le contraire
aurait surpris mais il a laissé le
sentier de l'acte iii de la
décentralisation en jachère sans rien
annoncé de neuf dans les nuages
s'accumulent sur les libertés locales
la recentralisation est en marche qui
place les communes sous la dépendance de
l'état et déresponsabilise les élus
l'autonomie financière recule devant l'
usine à gaz la compensation de la taxe
d'habitation
les dotations s'érode car elles ne sont
pas indexés sur l'inflation
les subventions discrétionnaire des
préfets sont préférés à la dotation
d'investissement qui seul est libre
d'emplois à travers les contrats de
cahors l'état s'immisce dans la libre
administration des collectivités
il oppose une fin de non recevoir au
rééquilibrage des relations entre
communes et intercommunalités rien n'est
fait pour faire obstacle au
communautarisme
sur ce point on sait maintenant ce dont
le président ne veut pas mais on ne sait
toujours pas ce qu'il veut alors
monsieur le premier ministre
allez-vous prendre la pleine mesure de
ses réalités et des menaces d' asphyxie
qui pèsent sur la démocratie locale
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président bah vous avez
évoqué brossé un tableau bien noir de la
réalité vécue par les maires
et après tout y est j'allais dire pour
reprendre votre formule soeur était
surprenant qu'il en soit autrement
mais je trouve monsieur le président bas
que je voudrais mettre peut-être
quelques nuances dans le discours que
vous venez de prononcer en faisant
d'abord appel à la faible expérience qui
est la mienne mais qui est en moi
s'agissant d'une municipalité une
expérience que je crois utile a souligné
je me souviens monsieur le président en
bas de la façon dont les maires je parle
que des mères en l'occurrence parce que
c'est la seule expérience dont je peux
faire état je me souviens de la réaction
des communes et des maires
quelques semaines après les élections
municipales de 2014
le président bart à un moment où il
n'était pas question d'une stabilité des
dotations
nous vous en souvenez mais où il était
question d'une diminution drastique et
pluriannuel des dotations je pense
monsieur le président bas que quand on
regarde la totalité du mandat municipal
qui a vocation à s'achever en mars 2020
et c'est comme ça en tout cas que pour
ma part je le regarderai on voit très
clairement une période où pendant trois
ans les dotations baisser les périmètres
des intercommunalités ont été modifiés
parfois brutalement et toute une série
de mesures sont venus transformer le
quotidien des maires et je crois
monsieur le président bak on voit bien
que dans les trois années qui ont suivi
cette baisse des dotations s'est arrêté
vous le savez parfaitement elle s'est
arrêtée et vous le savez parfaitement
les chiffres sont là et les chiffres
sont là et la commission des finances
veulent établir
c'est parfaitement documenté vous savez
très bien que nous avons décidé de ne
pas nous engager dans un big bang
périmétrique pour remodifier et les
répartitions de compétences lesquels
d'ailleurs après tous avaient parfois
été votée au titre d'une cmp monsieur le
président du sénat vous le savez
parfaitement et que nous avons décidé
faire en sorte de pouvoir assimiler
digérer si j'ose dire ces
transformations profondes qui avait été
réalisé jusqu'à 2017
ce que je constate monsieur le président
bah c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
remplacés et nous allons finir de
remplacer la taxe d'habitation par une
recette fiscale dynamique dans le cadre
d'un dispositif comme l'a
remarquablement dit monsieur le
secrétaire d'état il ya quelques minutes
qui garantit aux communes des ressources
pérennes
monsieur le président bah si la même
chose avec et je peux le dire j'étais
maire à l'époque si la même chose avait
été fait lorsque l'on a supprimé la taxe
professionnelle
c'était je crois à l'occasion du précéda
qui dut du quinquennat qui précédait le
quinquennat précédent et je crois que
vous voyez très bien ce à quoi je fais
référence si le même système avait été
mis en place à l'époque le même
exactement le même que celui que nous
proposons je suis convaincu que les
maires et les intercommunalités s'en
trouverait mieux autrement dit monsieur
le président je crois qu'on peut nuancer
ce que vous avez indiquée je crois qu'on
peut dire que le président a fait le
choix de la stabilité et qu'il a fait le
choix de la confiance
et j'observe car vous ne l'avez pas dit
mais vous auriez pu le dire monsieur le
président bas que c'est le président de
l'association des maires de france
lui-même lui même qui a fortement incité
à ce que s'agissant des projets relatifs
à la décentralisation omet la question
non pas à l'écart mais qu'on laisse
passer la période qui va jusqu'à mars et
aux échéances municipales ça n'est pas
le président qui l'a proposé c'est le
président de la mef qu'il nous y a
invité nous sommes en train de
travailler avec madame la ministre
jacqueline gourault avec sébastien
lecornu le ministre des collectivités
territoriales sur un projet de loi qui
pour la première fois ira bien plus loin
que tout ce qui a été fait jusqu'à
présent en matière de différenciation et
pourquoi en matière de différenciation
et comme vous êtes un homme qui croient
à la réalité des faits plutôt qu'aux
promesses je vous renvoie monsieur le
président bas à ce que nous avons fait
s'agissant de l'alsace
écoute des collectivités territoriales
loi de différenciation c'est un exemple
à mon avis éloquent est réel puisqu'il a
été voté par le sénat de ce que nous
sommes capables de faire et je crois que
ainsi nuancé
nos deux discours se répondent monsieur
le président philippe bas
monsieur le premier ministre philippe je
vous la corde il y a eu pire que votre
gouvernement
mais voyez-vous la commune n'est pas une
nostalgie les maires ne sont pas des
faire valoir
ils n'ont que faire des flatteries ils
appartiennent à la démocratie du concret
ce ne sont pas des marchands de bonheur
il est plus que temps d'inverser la
tendance à la recentralisation qu'il n'a
pas cessé de s'affirmer au cours des
dernières années
merci la parole est maintenant aux
présidents alain milon pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur clients contrairement
contrairement à ce qui est écrit sur le
tableau ma question ne s'adresse pas à
madame la ministre de la santé
mais monsieur le premier ministre du
fait que la semaine dernière pendant
l'examen du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale en présence de
madame buzyn le président de la
république a annoncé que des réformes de
l'hôpital seraient annoncées par le
premier ministre lui-même
donc ma question s'adresse à lui
puisqu'elle porte sur l'hôpital monsieur
le premier ministre il n'ya dans ce que
vous avez présenté ce matin qui esquisse
la grande réforme dans l'hôpital besoin
absolument rien de convaincant il a dit
attendez les professionnels de santé un
plan de sauvetage
ils n'ont eu que du rafistolage les
revalorisations se sont transformés en
prime ponctuelle soumise à conditions
les 300 millions d'euros de plus pour
2020 sont maîtres sont à mettre en
perspective avec le 800 millions d'euros
de déficit annuel des hôpitaux et après
avoir contribué à endetter les hôpitaux
faute de leur donner les moyens de
fonctionner vous vous contentez
d'alléger leurs dettes d'un tiers
monsieur prémunissent où nous avait
présenté le plan pour la santé 2022 il
ya 14 mois le plan pour les urgences il
y a 6 mois
manifestement ils n'ont pas atteint
leurs objectifs on peut d'ores et déjà
parier malheureusement qu'il en sera de
même pour vos dernières annonces
pourquoi monsieur le premier ministre
n'avez vous pas fait le choix d'une
réforme en profondeur de l'hôpital
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président me dont
vous m'interrogez sur le plan que ce
matin madame la ministre des solidarités
sont des solidarités et de la santé et
moi même avons présenté un mot d'abord
pour dire ce qui motive ce plan au delà
de ce décrochage et de ce sentiment
parfois d'abandon manifesté par toute
une série de professionnels qui font
vivre l'hôpital public une régulation
budgétaire terrible dans les dix
dernières années une transformation de
la gouvernance à l'inter de l'hôpital
qui a éloigné les médecins des lieux de
décisions une réforme profonde de
l'organisation territoriale qui a donné
le tournis à l'hôpital public ajoutez à
ça les 35 heures vous savez monsieur le
président qu'aucune de ces décisions
qu'aucune de ces décisions est dû à ce
gouvernement aucune aucune de ces
décisions est dû à ce gouvernement
non ça je peux vous le garantir
cette situation monsieur le président mi
longs monsieur le président millions
cette situation a conduit l'hôpital
public à une situation dont on pourrait
dire si on était dans l'aéronautique
qu'elle relève presque du décrochage
il faut éviter ce décrochage c'est à
dire qu'il faut donner de l'oxygène ou
du carburant cela dépend quel analogie
on veut travailler mais en tout cas de
l'oxygène à l'hôpital public pour qu'il
puisse pour qu'ils puissent passer cette
phase de transformation indispensable
qui a été décrite par madame la ministre
dans le cadre du plan ma santé 2022 et
j'observe monsieur le président billon
et je suis certain que vous l'observez
également que dans les manifestations
dans les remarques qui sont formulées
par les corps intermédiaires auquel vous
comme moi sommes attachés il n'y a pas
la contestation des orientations qui ont
été fixées par madame la ministre dans
le cadre de ma santé 2022 vous le savez
parfaitement
il ya au contraire une forme d'adhésion
mais mais il y a au contraire une forme
d'adhésion mais il y a la critique de ce
que ces pistes ne produiront leurs
effets que dans le temps et que
justement monsieur le président me dont
nous n'avons pas le temps parce qu'il y
a urgence celle chance c'est le sens du
plan d'action que nous avons présenté ce
matin qui n'est pas un petit plan
d'action monsieur le président mettre
sur la table sur les trois ans qui
viennent un milliard et demi d'euros
d'argent neuf frères y ajouter à ces 1
milliard et demi d'euros
les 450 millions plus exactement les 150
millions annuels pendant trois ans pour
financer de l'investissement médical et
du petit investissement médicale jeudi
petit entre guillemets parce qu'il ne
s'agit pas de construire des immenses
hôpitaux mais bien au contraire de
consacrer des ressources et des
ressources pérennes à de
l'investissement sur du matériel sur des
choses qui font cruellement défaut
vous savez comme moi monsieur le
président millions les chiffres de
l'hôpital sont terribles en dix ans
l'investissement spitalier a diminué a
été divisé par deux et dans la même
période
l'endettement de l'hôpital public a crû
de 40% ce phénomène rend insusceptible
les hôpitaux publics de dégager les
marges de manoeuvre qui lui permettent
d'envisager son ami et c'est précisément
la raison pour laquelle à côté de ce
milliard et demi d'euros plus les 450
millions
nous avons décidé
opéré une reprise de dette je n'ai pas
le souvenir mais je parle sous votre
contrôle monsieur le président je n'ai
pas le souvenir qu'une telle reprise de
dette était est couramment réalisé dans
le cadre de l'hôpital public 10
milliards de dette en trois ans et
massif 10 milliards de dette en trois
ans ces massifs et ça permet vous le
savez très bien compte tenu des taux
d'intérêt de dégager à terme c'est à
dire au bout des trois ans de la reprise
environ 800 millions environ 800
millions de marge de manoeuvre pour les
les c'est considérable
c'est évidemment considérable et il ne
s'agit pas simplement de moyens il
s'agit de remettre en avant
l'attractivité de l'hôpital public par
des primes c'est vrai par des parts des
capacités financières ni à la
disposition vous devriez y être
sensibles monsieur le président mis à la
disposition des chefs de service n'ont
pas décidé à paris ni à la disposition
des chefs de service pour les
accompagner dans leur projet médical
ça n'est pas rien c'est même assez rare
voilà ce que nous voulons faire et bien
d'autres choses encore ce plan d'action
renforcé ce plan d'urgence
il a vocation à faire en sorte que
l'hôpital public dépasse ce moment de
décrochage qui nous inquiète tous
légitimement moi je voudrais monsieur le
président félicitée la ministre des
solidarités de la santé et dire que le
travail engagé le travail engagé avec
les fédérations avec les nombreux
interlocuteurs que nous avons consultés
pour élaborer ce plan permet un bon plan
un vrai plan un plan pour l'hôpital
monsieur le président alain millions
oui mais merci monsieur le président je
n'ai pas la chance comme vous monsieur
promise d'avoir cinq minutes pour vous
répondre je vais reprendre un petit peu
au moins la crise de l'hôpital qui vient
en effet des 35 heures j'ai complètement
d'accord avec vous qui ensuite a été
évidemment compliquée par la loi hpst la
loi hpst que vous avez en tant que
députés voter je vous le rappelle
monsieur le premier ministre toutes les
mesures que vous avez prises sont en
effet pas acceptable encore parce que
insuffisante
je voudrais vous donner quelques pistes
supplémentaires il faudrait que vous
puissiez dans le cas d'un programme
donné leur autonomie aux hôpitaux
débureaucratiser l'hôpital et rendre le
pouvoir à ceux qui ce pagne et pourquoi
pas remettre en place des conseils
d'administration plutôt que des conseils
de surveillance accepté de donner une
juste rémunération aux personnels qui
sont les moins bien payés 2 en europe et
régionalisée l'organisation de la santé
pourrait impliquer les collectivités
locales et se rapprochait de besoin de
terrain merci merci
la parole est à notre collègue annie
guillemot pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
quel premier ministre pourrait profiter
de quelques secondes
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le secrétaire d'état en charge
de la protection de l'enfance ce 20
novembre le 30e anniversaire de la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant
notre pays a signé le 26 janvier 90 de
même que 192 pays
mais de nombreux droits de l'enfant
peine encore à être respecté je veux
saluer tout particulièrement l'unicef
qui oeuvrent au quotidien pour le
respect de cette convention dans le
monde convention qui introduit le
concept d' intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
et en fait non plus un objet de droit
mais au dessus j'ai salué aussi des
bénévoles des centaines d'associations
qui partout sur nos territoires
s'investissent et enfin les maires qui
joue un rôle essentiel particulièrement
dans les villes amies des enfants comme
l'était ma ville de bron l'une des
premières à adhérer à ce réseau porté
par l'association des maires de france
dont c'est le congrès l unicef
malgré ces efforts quelques réalités 1,8
million d'enfants en france est
adolescent pauvre 17% de ses enfants
sont très jeunes enfants moins de 10 ans
plus de six cent mille enfants vivent
dans des conditions indignes
et ce n'est pas le budget du logement
que vous avez décidé d'amputer de près
de six milliards d'euros sur le
quinquennat qui va améliorer la
situation
un enfant mort tous les cinq jours de
violences intrafamiliales
cent cinquante cinq mille sont victimes
chaque année de violences sexuelles
le récent rapport du défenseur des
droits relative aux violences subies par
les enfants au sein des institutions
publiques pointe également qu'elles sont
une réalité dans le quotidien des
enfants et que le fonctionnement de ses
institutions publiques est susceptible
en lui même d'induire des violences
faites aux enfants dont elles ont la
charge
aussi en ce jour anniversaire et alors
que le gouvernement vient d'annoncer un
plan pour lutter contre les violences
faites aux enfants quelles décisions
concrètes contre prendre le gouvernement
pour mieux protéger nos enfants
répondent la parole est au secrétaire
d'état auprès de la ministre des
solidarités de la santé d'un truc si
administre driller attaquez vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame c'est la triste messieurs les
sénateurs
madame la sénatrice permettez moi en ce
jour anniversaire de saluer la présence
d'enfants de la fondation actions
enfance qui assistent à nos à nos débats
aujourd'hui saluer salué avec vous
effectivement l'unicef l'ensemble des
associations et des professionnels qui
oeuvrent pour la protection de nos de
nos enfants et notamment la dynamique
qui organise un grand événement ce soir
auquel le gouvernement sera sera
représentée vous c'est vous le savez
bien madame la sénatrice le gouvernement
n'a pas attendu ce 30e anniversaire ni
même ma nomination à ce secrétariat
d'état il ya désormais dix mois pour
oeuvrer en faveur des droits des enfants
et s'évertuer à mieux respecter encore
les recommandations formulées par le
comité du droit des enfants des nations
unies quand jean michel blanquer porte
la scolarisation obligatoire à 3 ans
c'est bien le droit à l'éducation qui
est qui et porter la question du droit à
la santé avec agnès buzyn et le plan de
priorité prévention ou encore
l'instauration des onze vaccins
obligatoires
l'action menée par sophie cluzel pour
l'école inclusive ou encore le repérage
précoce des enfants avec troupe de
spectre de l'autisme afin qu'ils soient
mieux accompagnés concourt aussi à cela
ou encore la nécessité d'une justice
adaptée porté par la garde des sceaux
dans le cadre de la route de l'or la
réforme pardon de l' ordonnance de 1945
pour autant il y a un droit sans lequel
aucun autre droit n'est possible c'est
le droit à la sécurité la sécurité à la
fois matérielle et affective
le docteur martin blanchet lâchait dans
le cadre d'une conférence de consensus
avait évoqué ce qu'elle appelait le méta
besoin et c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai présenté effectivement ce matin le
président de la république à l'unesco a
pu présenter un certain nombre de
mesures pour lutter contre les violences
faites aux enfants vous avez rappelé un
certain nombre de chiffres
c'est absolument inadmissible dans un
pays comme le nôtre que les enfants
puissent vivre ce type de violence 22
mesures pour garantir la sécurité de nos
enfants partout tout le temps dans les
institutions de la république vous avez
raison de le dire à l'école le cyber
harcèlement mais évidemment dans les
institutions pour les enfants en
situation de handicap ou encore les
institutions de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance garantir à tous les enfants
coquin aucune grande personne en contact
avec ses enfants ne puissent avoir été
par le passé
acteur d'actes pédophiles mine elle
c'est une des mesures fortes de ce plan
madame la sénatrice madame limo
oui mais monsieur le secrétaire d'état
en 2018 plus de 12 cents enfants à
mayotte ont été mis en prison dans 208
enfants aussi en métropole qui ont été
aussi en rétention alors comme le
revendique aujourd'hui 35 associations
ou ong collectif dont l'unicef
il faut passer de la convention aux
actes en s'engageant sur un objectif de
zéro enfants dans la rue d'ici 2022 et
un observatoire national de non
scolarisation pour des pour pouvoir
détecter les jeunes qui sont vulnérables
merci la parole est à notre collègue
rené paul savary pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
dell voit le président de la république
l'a toujours dit pour qu'il y ait une
réforme des retraites en 2025 faut que
le système soit équilibré et d'ailleurs
monsieur le premier ministre l'a bien
confirmé devant le conseil économique et
social ce qui l'a bien dit qu'on ne
pouvait pas laisser filer un déficit que
vivre en déficit n'était pas forcément
le signe d'une bonne santé ou d'une
bonne gestion que le rapport cotisants
pensionnés n'étant pas favorable le
système allait se dégrader et il a même
été précisée à rodez que si le déficit
est entre vite et 10 milliards et ben il
faudra dire qu'il faut travailler
davantage
le rapport du cor a révélé ce qui avait
déjà été dit
en juin savoir un déficit autour de 10
ans de 8 à 10,7 milliards d'euros
donc je voulais savoir maintenant que
nous sommes au pied du mur et c'est au
pied du mur qu'on voit le maçon donc
quelles sont les réformes que vous allez
proposer en tout cas les mesures que
vous allez proposer pour équilibrer le
système de santé pourront répondre la
parole l'état aux commissaires aux
retraites
jean paul delevoye monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur rené paul savary
je m'adresse à vous en tant que
rapporteur du projet retraites mais
aussi en tant que membre du conseil
d'orientation des retraites et je
voudrais donc saluer aussi sous la
houlette du président millions et du
rapporteur général jean marie
vanlerenberghe
tous les travaux qui ont été engagés par
le sénat pour soutenir un système en
points et toutes les contributions qui
sont les vôtres pour pouvoir trouver un
juste équilibre dans un système de
répartition entre les jeunes actifs et
des retraités
il vous a pas échappé que le conseil
d'orientation des retraites tient son
conseil d'administration demain et je
pense que votre intervention s'inscrit
probablement dans l'intervention que
vous allez porter à la connaissance des
membres pluraliste de ce conseil pour
justifier votre position et vos
solutions et donc par respect pour les
membres bien évidemment le président
bras remettra demain officiellement
premier ministre son rapport le premier
ministre le 25 et le 26 recevra la
totalité des organisations syndicales
pour leur demander très concrètement
suite à la commande qu'il a fait 19
septembre de dire quel est l'état réel
du déficit du système des retraites car
elle nous a pas échappé qu'entre la
campagne présidentielle il y a eu deux
ou trois estimations qui pouvait créer
un trouble ou à une interrogation avec y
compris des raisonnements curieux qui
fait que plus on diminue le nombre de
fonctionnaires et plus le solde devient
déficitaire dans le système des
retraites
l'engagement que nous avons pris par un
système de répartition dont le plafond
sera le plus élevé d
il développe et c'est d'assumer
d'assumer l'universalité des droits mais
aussi la responsabilité qui consiste à
ne pas faire porter sur les jeunes le
poids d'un déficit que nous n'aurons pas
réglé
et donc nous assumons dans les discours
du président et du premier ministre et
dans les miens que suite à cette remise
de rapports des décisions seront prises
pour assurer aux futures générations
un système juste équilibre est solide
parce que nous ferons en sorte qu'il
soit installé sur une base de zéro
déficit mais si pour vous monsieur
savary merci merci monsieur le ministre
mais c'est votre réponse c'était pas ma
question
wesley a porté sur les mesures à prendre
pour résorber le déficit on sait bien
que dans le système actuel soit pour
équilibrer en baisse les pensions et
dans le plfss c'est une orientation de
vous donner soit on augmente les
cotisations pour augmenter les recettes
mais on sait que ce pays est
suffisamment chargée soit on étudie des
mesures d'âge parce qu'avec une
espérance de vie plus longue
on peut peut-être songer à répartir un
temps de travail plus l'eau par rapport
à un temps de retraite plus long mais
dans un système à points monsieur le
ministre vous introduisez un critère
nouveau qui est la valeur du point
elle système n'est pas équilibré bas
plus le point et peuple les retraites
sont basses et au lieu d'avoir des
gagnants et des perdants vous pouvez
avoir que des perdants système n'est pas
équilibré donc il est temps de
véritablement si on veut rétablir la
confiance de dire la vérité aux gens
parce qu'à vouloir tout changer
parfois on change rien
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue michel
calvet pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
il avait la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues nous sommes tous
particulièrement attaché à la france
rurale la france rurale parce que
beaucoup de nos concitoyens y vivent
parce qu'aussi on y trouve des produits
de grande qualité solides la gastronomie
française est réputée mais aussi liquide
nos terroirs sont reconnus au niveau des
boissons que ce soit au niveau du vin
l'évocation des côtes du rhône du
bordelais de la bourgogne mais aussi du
cidre de bretagne le pastis de marseille
ou de porte à renier
bref tout ce qui fait la force de nos
terroirs et je dois vous dire que
beaucoup de nos concitoyens ont été
étonnés quand ils ont entendu monsieur
le ministre de l'agriculture et
l'alimentation dimanche dernier prenez
la tolérance zéro concernant la colère
consommation de boissons et la conduite
nous avons déjà un arsenal répressif
extrêmement fort que veux tu on veut ton
encore pénaliser les territoires ruraux
déjà affectée par la réduction à 80
km/heure de la circulation sur les axes
secondaires veux-t-on les pénaliser
encore non nous apprécions tous les
boissons il faut les consommer avec
modération donc je souhaite savoir
monsieur le premier ministre
quelle est la position du gouvernement
sur ce sujet on veut répondre la parole
au ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner merci mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs c'est le
président monsieur le sénateur canivez
vous avez raison nos terroirs sont
riches en gastronomie vous dites cela
est celui qui vous répond à porter
pendant de longues années la chaîne
nationale des bistrots de pays le
dernier commerce de proximité
et puis vous avez évoqué aussi nos
produits liquides du terroir évoquant le
pastis de marseille permettez moi
d'évoquer celui de forcalquier quand
même d'être mon meilleur mais au-delà de
ce clin d'oeil monsieur le sénateur ce
dont on parle c'est la lutte pour la
sécurité routière
c'est ce combat majeur qui doit tous
nous rassembler pour sauver des vies à
la fois contre les accidents mortels
mais aussi contre ces accidents
extrêmement grave qui laisse des traces
humaines voire inhumaines tout au long
d'une vie et nous sommes totalement
mobilisés sur ce sujet et c'est vrai que
dans le cadre du comité interministériel
de sécurité routière du 9 janvier
plusieurs mesures avaient été proposées
ont été mises en place dans la lutte
contre l'alcoolémie
mais lutter contre l'alcoolémie ça n'est
pas interdire de boire et je vais être
extrêmement clair monsieur le sénateur
non le gouvernement n'envisage pas de
revenir sur le taux d'alcoolémie au
volant et de l'abaisser à zéro gramme
par litre de sang
mais monsieur le sénateur chacun sait
ici qu'il n'est pas sain de boire avant
de prendre le volant et c'est cela que
le ministre de l'agriculture a voulu
rappeler c'est cette invitation à la
citoyenneté à la fois pour se protéger
soi même mais aussi pour protéger tous
les autres usagers de la route et celles
et ceux qui ne sont pas forcément au
volant mais nous ne sommes pas
favorables à revenir à zéro g pour
plusieurs raisons notamment des raisons
très pragmatiques
d'abord parce que entre 0 et 0,5 g ça
concerne assez peu d'accidents de la
route et d'accidents mortels encore
moins la moyenne dans les accidents
mortels c'est 1,5 g et vous voyez nous
sommes sur des proportions largement
supérieur et d'autre part parce que ça
obligerait à mobiliser nos forces de
sécurité intérieure pour des contrôles
qui serait aléatoire et peu efficace
alors même que nous savons que nous
aurons besoin de les avoir mobilisé pour
la sécurité des français merci
/ cad v merci monsieur le ministre
d'avoir rassuré les populations des
territoires ruraux c'était important
parce que ils n'ont pas d'autre
alternative que de prendre la voiture et
je suis totalement d'accord avec vous
sur le fait qu'il faut consommer avec la
plus grande modération
mais ceci ne doit pas nous empêcher
d'apprécier les produits du terroir ne
doit pas nous empêcher pour les uns et
les autres
la sociabilité sur les territoires
ruraux parce que il est important qu'on
puisse continuer à fréquenter les débits
de boissons il est important que l'on
puisse aller déjeuner chez des amis ou
chez des parents sans avoir à craindre
quoi que ce soit il est important qu'on
puisse continuer à se déplacer
on vous remercie de bienvenue et veiller
à ce que il ne soit pas si à l'avenir
pour la liberté des ruraux
merci la parole est à notre collègue
philippe dominati pour le groupe l'est
républicain le vélo couché président
madame la ministre à bercy quand il faut
on sait être pragmatique
à l'occasion de la fusion entre fiat et
le groupe psa l'état actionnaire a
indiqué le chemin de l'efficacité en
soyons en choisissant comme siège social
amsterdam
il faut dire que c'est pas nouveau ça
s'est fait dans le passé pour renault
nissan
ça c'est fait pour airbus et pour
quelques groupes privés non on croyait
que ce ton était révolue alors il faut
reconnaître que l'on peut être séduit
par la fiscalité sur les sociétés
les grandes sociétés aux pays bas on
peut être séduit également par la
stabilité fiscale
et puis l'état néerlandais utiliser un
report comme un point d'attraction pour
les grandes entreprises internationales
pendant le même temps le patron de tesla
devait choisir l'implantation de son
usine en europe
il a choisi berlin il a choisi berlin
parce que nous avions plusieurs sites à
proposer
vous pouvez proposer sa clé pour les
ingénieurs
mais il trouvait qu'à berlin il y avait
des gens
d'ailleurs il y avait un problème de
foncier vous pouvez avoir lampre-isd adp
mais il a préféré berlin les anars au
port public la russie qui est un outil
industriel et parle du futur un report
mais surtout c'était la faisabilité de
faire vite pour construire vite
alors je voudrais savoir qui est bercy
s'occuper de traiter ces deux grands
industriels parce que l'investissement
d'un côté c'était 4 milliards avec entre
5000 et 8000 emplois pour tesla
j'ai oublié de vous dire qu'il y à un
fabricant japonais de batterie qui lui
investi quelques semaines avant deux
mineurs à berlin je voulais savoir qu'à
bercy s'occuper de ça ou au gouvernement
pour faire en sorte que la france reste
attractive
quand vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances madame agnès
pannier rue nashville avait la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur dominati vous avez raison c'est
deux dossiers celui que vous évoquez
l'investissement dans une usine de
batteries électriques d'une part où
l'investissement dans une usine de tesla
également d'autre part montre
l'importance de mener une politique
d'attractivité sur le territoire
français et je veux dire que sur ce
sujet là en termes d'attraction des
projets industriels et des projets de
r&d
j'ai envie de prendre les chiffres tout
simplement et de pas prendre quelques
cas qui ne sont pas anecdotiques car
important mais qui néanmoins ne donne
pas la réalité de l'image en 2018
i want dance et niang bardon indiqué que
la france accueillait plus de 330
projets d'investissements industriels
là où la turquie en deuxième position en
accueillait à peu près 200 et là où leur
l'allemagne que vous avez cités était à
150 donc fait actuellement en 2018 la
france accueille deux fois plus de
projets industriels que l'allemagne
prenons les chiffres de la r&d par
exemple et bien en termes de centres de
r&d toujours les chiffres 2018 toujours
cette enquête extérieure ce ne sont pas
les chiffres du gouvernement qu on
pourrait critiquer éventuellement
toujours cette enquête extérieure montre
que la france accueille autant de sites
de r&d que l'allemagne et le royaume uni
réunis et pourquoi cela parce que depuis
deux ans et demi nous avons mené une
politique d'attractivité vous en
connaissez les fondements cette
politique d'attractivité c'est une
politique fiscale adapté pour attirer
les investissements étrangers en france
pour permettre aux français aussi
d'investir en france c'est toute la
politique fiscale sur le la taxation du
capital
c'est également une politique qui
facilite les conditions d'emploi et qui
se facilite la formation car vous le
savez le premier obstacle aujourd'hui
pour la formation pour le développement
des entreprises c'est le recrutement
ce n'est pas le manque d'argent enfin
dernier point je vous indique que le
locaux clairs simplification et le
dernier onglet c'est celui dont nous
nous emparons notamment dans le cadre du
pacte de production je vous remercie
monsieur 2010 madame la ministre vous
m'avez répondu personne à bercy n'a fait
le lien avec ces deux industriels
évidemment sans doute on était occupée
pour reporter la baisse de l'impôt sur
les grandes sociétés
un budget ultérieure on était peut-être
occupé pour faire une taxe sur les
bureaux ciblées en ile de france
on était peut-être occupé pour une taxe
sur les billets d'avion
on était peut-être occupé pour un
prélèvement au coût financier le contrat
plan est bien en réalité j'aimerais
qu'on s'occupe de la région capitale
parce que manifestement au gouvernement
ça n'a pas l'air d'être une priorité
merci
la parole est à notre collègue joël
labbé pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole si le président chers
collègues une question à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture monsieur le
ministre lors du dernier comité est un
région vous êtes prononcé contre une
augmentation du transfert actuel de 7 5%
du premier pilier vers le second pilier
de la pac pour 2020 estimant que le taux
actuel suffirait à garantir le bon
fonctionnement des mesures jusqu'à la
fin de la programmation
or on sait que cette somme est déjà bien
insuffisante
les régions ont déjà consommé une grande
partie voire la quasi totalité de
l'enveloppé prévue pour les essais et
les aides au bio ainsi certaines
restreignent déjà l'accès à ces
financements réservant par exemple les
aides à la conversion bio aux seuls
projets portés par les jeunes
agriculteurs
comment comptez vous répondre aux
demandes communes des agriculteurs et
des citoyens afin d'assurer les
financements nécessaires à la transition
agro écologiques dans les territoires
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur la baie il vous reste une
minute 4 secondes pour faire une
réplique qui à mon sens est déjà écrite
mais je vais vous dire que la question
que vous posez et je vais vous dire je
veux vous dire que la question que vous
posez s'il n'y a pas de prêt ni dégâts
je vais vous dire que la question que
vous posez le risque que vous évoquez
n'existe pas une organisation syndicale
la levée lors du contrat état région
l'unanimité de ce contrat etat-région
estimé que le prélèvement de 7,53 %
entre le premier pilier et le deuxième
pilier avait suffi en 2019 et suffira en
2020 et nous avons décidé ensemble avec
le président morin avec régions de
france et le premier ministre nous a
autorisés à le faire que les régions
puissent surfer de la sueur
programmation donc bien encore de
l'argent les régions offert de la sueur
programmation en
il vint et nous avons convenu
unanimement qu'il n'y avait aucun risque
que les mae sai et le bureau serait fait
les aides seraient apportés par les
régions parleurs sur programmation et
que l'état le valider quant à
l'installation oui c'est un choix nous
avons voulu privilégier le travail
accompli par les jeunes agriculteurs qui
connaissent très bien les dossiers de
l'installation
et c'est sur la base de leurs
propositions que nous voulons travailler
ce n'est pas exclusif mais sur la base
de propositions
donc monsieur le sénateur je vous le dis
j'ai déjà eu ce genre de question il n'y
a pas de risque on ne peut pas
travailler en l'air sur des réflexions
théoriques
pratiquement il n'y aura pas de région
qui ne pourront pas aller au bout des
ailes qu'elles doivent apporter dans les
mae sai et dans le bio c'est
l'engagement qu'ont pris unanimement
entre régions de france et le
gouvernement
et je pense c'est ce qui se passera en
2020 comme cela se passe en 2019
nous gardons le même taux de 7,53 parce
que nous pensons qu'il est suffisant et
la sueur programmation des régions leur
permettra de tout financer je vous
remercie monsieur l'abbé
monsieur le ministre c'est absolument
insuffisant et votre votre réponse ne me
satisfait pas du tout en d'autres temps
elle aurait même pu énerver mais puisque
vous avez dit même que puisque vous
m'avez dit que tout était préparé pour
vous répondre
c'est à auprès de monsieur le premier
ministre que je vais répliqué parce que
ces sujets là on sait à quel niveau il
se joue c'est pas au niveau du ministre
de l'agriculture c'est un autre niveau
monsieur monsieur le premier ministre on
sait que vous êtes allé qu à l'écouté du
monde agricole
mais vous êtes surtout à l'ecoute
d'étonnantes d'un modèle agricole se
tourne ce modèle agricole qui est en
difficulté qui a emmené une partie
importante de nos agriculteurs en grande
difficulté en grande pauvreté en grande
désespérance pour une partie importante
on le sait il y à des alternatives pour
cela il faut se donner les moyens
alors les tenants du du lait du modèle
tuque qui se continue alors qu'il
devrait muter
ils sont leur conclure il est hors de
question
alors il est hors de question de sortir
du glyphosate il est hors de question
d'imposer des zones de non traitement
on va devoir faire tout ça et monsieur
le ministre je vous invite à écouter
toutes les cloches agricoles parce
qu'elle nous parce qu'il n'y a pas qu'un
seul son de cloche vous remercie merci
la parole est à notre collègue marie
pierre monnier pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain sur collègues
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
les chutes de neige de jeudi dernier ont
provoqué une situation difficile et
inédite dans de nombreux départements en
particulier dans la drôme
j'associe donc mes deux collègues
drômois gilbert bouchet et bernard lui à
cette question en drôme ce sont 80 mille
foyers qui ont été privés d'électricité
et hier soir 7000 étaient encore
concernés pas d'électricité en cette
saison cela veut dire plus de chauffage
plus d'eau chaude parfois même plus
d'eau du tout plus de communication
possibles depuis six jours cela a été
ponctuellement dramatique et pourrait
l'être encore si nous n'agissons pas
cette situation est due à des chutes de
neige abondantes précoce avec une neige
lourde et collante à une période où les
arbres portent encore leurs feuilles et
sont donc plus sensible au poids de la
neige
beaucoup sont tombés sur les routes et
sur les installations électriques
souvent aussi les installations elles
mêmes ont cédé pilonnent compris je veux
rendre hommage aux agents donné 10 qui
se sont sont intervenus aussi vite
qu'ils le pouvaient mais surtout salué
le dévouement des maire et de nombreux
élus qui sont restés sur le pont nuitées
jour et tiennent bon
même si ils et elles sont épuisées par
cette épreuve
aujourd'hui cela fait six jours que cela
dure et ils se sentent bien seuls face
au désarroi et aux interrogations
légitimes des habitants ce qui se passe
au moment où je vous parle est grave
les plus fragiles sont en danger et il
faut y apporter des solutions
sans tarder à l'avenir avec le
changement climatique ce type d'épisode
neigeux risque de se reproduire
aussi madame la ministre compte tenu de
la situation et des dégâts très
importants
je souhaite vous vous soumettre trois
questions que va faire l'état pour
rétablir l'électricité dans tous les
foyers encore concernés quel nouveau
dispositif pourrait être mise en oeuvre
pour sécuriser les réseaux électriques
afin d'éviter que cela se reproduise
peut-on envisager que ce type
d'événement puissent être reconnues
comme catastrophe naturelle ou trouver
un autre moyen d'indemnisation pour vous
répondre la parole
l'auteur d'état auprès de la ministre de
transition écologique et solidaire mais
l'embargo de la ministre devait la
parole monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice monnier vous avez raison c'est
un épisode très difficile qui a été vécu
dans le grand sud ouest depuis la fin de
la semaine dernière je me suis dans le
grand sud s dans le grand sud s depuis
la fin de la semaine dernière je me suis
rendu dans la drôme à côté de valence
vendredi dernier et je voudrais à mon
tour rendre hommage aux élus aux
gendarmes aux pompiers aux renforts
militaires aux agents des néo 10 aux
agents de rte qui se sont mobilisés sans
relâche face à cet épisode vous l'avez
dit cet épisode est due à de la neige
lourde et collante qui est tombé
rapidement sur des arbres qui avaient
encore des feuilles avec de nombreux
arbres qui sont tombés des routes qu'il
a fallu déblayer beaucoup de poteaux qui
sont tombés qui a fallu remettre en
service
aucune visibilité des hélicoptères qui
ne pouvaient pas décoller gand qui ne
pouvait pas faire suivre les lignes 330
mille foyers ont été privés
d'électricité
la situation et tentera de revenir à la
normale mais ça n'est pas complètement
fini à la fin du week end
il restait environ trente mille foyers
essentiellement dans la drôme en ardèche
il en reste encore quelques milliers
aujourd'hui il en reste encore sept
mille dans la drôme et quelques-uns en
ardèche
face à cette situation ce sont 2300
agents qui ont été mobilisés qui ont
travaillé jour et nuit pour remettre les
lignes en service ce sont des places
d'hébergement des centres d'hébergement
qui ont été ouverts par la préfecture
notamment la préfecture de la drôme
ce sont des groupes électrogènes qui ont
été mises à disposition
même si bien sûr usage de ces groupes
électrogènes doit être fait avec
beaucoup de précaution puisque nous
avons déploré un accident en isère pour
la suite est né dix continuent à
enterrer des lignes 18 mille kilomètres
de lignes sont enterrés chaque année 50
% du réseau est enterré en ce qui
concerne les catastrophes naturelles les
assurances peuvent déjà indemnisé
l'effet de neige ou de grêle et donc
nous n'avons pas besoin dans ce cas
particulier de déclarer l'état de
catastrophe naturelle
merci madame la mini par en les
maintenant notre collègue laure darcos
meurent groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics
monsieur le ministre le président de la
république m les élus d'ailleurs il n'a
cessé de le répéter hier lors du congrès
des maires de france
mais votre gouvernement a quand même la
fâcheuse habitude de s'immiscer dans les
finances locales
concernant la taxe d'habitation françois
baroin a eu raison de rappeler hier au
président de la république que vous avez
décidé de supprimer un impôt qui ne vous
appartient pas il faut que la
considération aille de pair avec le
respect alors de respect il en est
question quand votre gouvernement dépose
sur le projet de loi de finances pour
2020 un amendement prévoyant qu'une
partie des droits de mutation à titre
onéreux perçue par les départements
franciliens et la ville de paris sera
prélevée au profit de la société du
grand paris
excusez du peu 75 millions d'euros en
2020 puis 60 millions d'euros par an à
partir de 2021 pour financer tenez vous
bien les engagements de l'état inscrit
dans le contrat de plan etat-région
2020-2022 sur les transports coupons mon
département plus de 3 millions d'euros
alors même que l'essonne pâtit
d'infrastructures de transport surchargé
est vieillissante
non content d'avoir reporté la
construction de la ligne 18 qui devait
dynamiser le plateau de saclay des
yvelines jusqu en essonne où le charles
de gaulle express qui devait faciliter
l'accès au village olympique en
seine-saint-denis l'état nous ponctionne
a posteriori pour sa mauvaise gestion
je veux bien vous accordez vous n'êtes
pas les seuls responsables du passif de
la sgp
mais quand on exerce des compétences il
faut en assumer les responsabilités et
le financement aussi ma question est
simple sur le ministre
quand ce gouvernement va-t-il cesser de
dévitaliser les collectivités locales et
en particulier nos départements au
mépris des élus et des populations que
nous servons et cela vous n'avez compris
n'est pas qu'un problème franciliens
merci pour vous répondre la parole et
hop secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
d'action des comptes publics messieurs
olivier du vous avez la parole
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice laure darcos les
impôts n'appartiennent ni souvenir aux
collectivités ni à l'état ils sont payés
par les contribuables et l'objectif de
ce gouvernement est de baisser les
impôts et de rendre du pouvoir d'achat
aux contribuables vous poser deux
questions en tout cas deux
interpellations
la première concerne le financement des
programmes d'infrastructures prévus par
la société du grand paris
nous avons pour financer ses travaux ses
infrastructures retenues de solutions
une première à l'initiative d'un rapport
parlementaire d'une initiative
parlementaire qui consiste à regarder
comment moduler la taxe sur les bureaux
et cette disposition a été adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale vous aurez à la
regarder bientôt et une hotte consistant
effectivement affecté une fraction ddmt
au des départements de la petite
couronne sur le financement de ces
infrastructures
cela répond à un besoin
d'infrastructures vous l'avez noté
et peut-être que vous auriez pu dans
votre intervention relativiser le coût
pour les départements rappelant de
combien les dm théo avait été dynamique
au cours des dernières années ce qui
relativise grandement la fonction
puisque vous avez utilisé ce terme qui
est ainsi concernée au delà vous nous
demandez comment est ce que le
gouvernement entend continuer à aider
les collectivités territoriales et vous
nous dites même train d'une forme de
dévitalisation je vous réponds par trois
chiffres
le premier chiffre concerne les
dotations dotation de fonctionnement
ce gouvernement a fait le choix de la
stabilité et vous aurez l'occasion de
voir dans le projet de loi de finances
que le total des concours financiers de
l'état aux collectivités va même passer
de 48,3 49,1 milliards d'euros en 2020
après 11 milliards de baisses de 2014 à
2017 les juste et utile de rappeler la
stabilité le 2e chiffre c'est le
maintien des dotations d'investissement
deux milliards d'investissements pour le
bloc de dotation pour le bloc local
auquel il faut ajouter 7 milliards de
droit commun pour participer aux
investissements des collectivités au
total l'état consacre 9 milliards au
soutien à l'investissement des
collectivités locales et le troisième
c'est la solidarité avec une déçue une
dsr les dotations de péréquation qui
progresse au même niveau que l'année
précédente soit 90 millions d'euros pour
la déçu et pour la dsr c'est la
stabilité c'est la lisibilité
c'est la capacité pour les hurlus à
prévoir et avoir les moyens de leur
action c'est aussi comme ça qu'on
construit une contraction le contrat de
confiance avec des collectivités locales
en madame darcos et monsieur ministre a
d'abord il s'agit de tous les
départements franciliens et c'est un peu
simple de payer ses dettes en prenant
l'argent des autres
c'est qu'on ait fait des impôts mais
c'était pas cessé pas l'état décidé ça
et heureusement que les collectivités ne
sont pas sont plus responsables que
l'état est peut-être faudra-t-il un jour
réfléchir un gel total de tous les
cofinancements dans nos territoires
respectifs pour mettre l'état face à ses
responsabilités à mesure unilatérale
conclut l'ont su littéral merci monsieur
le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres merci nos
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu le mercredi 27 novembre à 15 heures
la séance va être suspendue elle sera
reprise à 16h35 pour l'examen de la
proposition de loi tendant à la création
de délégations parlementaires aux droits
de l'enfant
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement au sénat que
vous avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur notre antenne avec
plusieurs moments forts aujourd'hui en
lien avec des sujets majeurs du moment
d'abord sur le plan hôpital et ensuite
sur l'actualité et bien du congrès des
maires de france alors ces deux moments
forts ont été l'occasion de deux face à
face quand le premier ministre a fait
face aux deux présidents des commissions
des lois et des affaires sociales
philippe bas alain milon la droite
sénatoriale tout d'abord qui ne cache
pas ses réserves sur le plan hôpital
le président l'actionnaire social alain
milon qui a parlé de rafistolage avec
rien de convaincant je cite dans ce plan
pour les pour l'hôpital par exemple il a
pointé le fait que le gouvernement
prévoit des primes ponctuelles sous
conditions au lieu des revalorisations
de salaires nécessaires à l'hôpital il a
demandé pourquoi ne pas avoir fait le
choix d'une réforme en profondeur de
l'hôpital public et c'est donc edouard
philippe qui lui a répondu en
revendiquant une continuité avec les
précédentes lois porté par agnès buzyn
qui avaient des mesures sur le long
cours qui ne produisait lors leur effet
qu'avec du temps or il n'y a plus de
temps a dit edouard philippe doux ce
plan qui vise à rendre de l'attractivité
à l'hôpital public
second moment fort avec le face à face
entre edouard philippe et philippe bas
le président de la commission des lois
du sénat sur l'actualité des mères mais
tout d'abord direction la salle des
conférences avec agnès buzyn à votre
micro alexandre poussard mais où agnès
buzyn on a entendu les mots assez
sévères du président de la commission
des affaires sociales alain milon qui
parle de plan de rafistolage
une partie du personnel hospitalier
n'est pas vraiment satisfait par ce plan
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez
c'est un investissement sans précédent
dans l'hôpital public ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui c'est de rattraper
en fait des années de sous
investissement nous héritons d'une
situation
vous le savez où l'hôpital a été la
variable d'ajustement du système de
santé
j'ai commencé avec ma santé 2022 ré
équilibrer cela parc doit réaliser dans
le système de santé l'organisation des
soins de ville j'ai dégagé du temps
médical
favorisant des délégations de tâches
j'ai réarmer les hôpitaux de proximité
en mettant vraiment le patient au coeur
de notre système de santé
mais il faut aller plus vite pour
l'hôpital car il souffre d'un défaut
d'attractivité
donc aujourd'hui nous avons décidé
d'investir investir de l'argent frais 1
5 milliard d'euros dans les trois ans
qui viennent
d'argent nouveau pour les hôpitaux pour
leur redonner de marge de manoeuvre
avec des budgets en hausse de 0 2 %
garanti pendant trois ans je rappelle
que les budgets hospitaliers n'ont pas
cessé de baisser depuis dix ans c'était
la première fois l'année dernière que
nous augmentions les tarifs hospitaliers
et là nous garantissons sur trois ans
des tarifs en hausse pour tous les
hôpitaux
nous réinvestissons également dans les
outils du quotidien ce qui va permettre
aux professionnels de travailler dans de
bonnes conditions
cet investissement 150 millions d'euros
par an seront données aux chefs de
service aux chefs de pôles pour qu'ils
organisent avec leur équipe
la répartition de ces budgets entre
repeindre éventuellement une salle
réinvestir dans des brancards dans des
lits dans un scanner je ne sais je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils choisiront ce sera à
eux de le faire mais surtout nous
donnons des primes pour reconnaître
l'engagement des professionnels dans
l'hôpital nous donnons notamment une
prime à toutes les aides soignantes qui
travaille aujourd'hui en ehpad ou en
gériatrie 100 euros net par mois
soixante mille personnes qui vont en
bénéficier et ça revient vraiment à
reconnaître le travail très difficile
qu'elles font au quotidien
nous avons lutté contre l'intérêt
médical nous allons simplifier les
procédures au sein de la ville de
l'hôpital et revoir toute la gouvernance
ce sont des annonces qui n'ont jamais
été fait je crois que les hospitaliers
l'attendent et justement sur ces primes
certains syndicats du personnel
hospitalier de mende et des
revalorisations salariales
s'il ya des syndicats qui appellent à la
poursuite des grèves qu'est ce que vous
leur dites
j'ai vu aujourd'hui j'ai rencontré tous
les acteurs notamment les présidents des
commissions médicales d'établissement
les directeurs généraux des hôpitaux
publics
j'ai rencontré les fédérations
hospitalières tous ont dit que ces
mesures allaient dans le très bon sens
après certains veulent des
revalorisations de tout le personnel
médical nous savons que ça mobilise
aujourd'hui des budgets sans forcément
être transformant sans changer vraiment
les conditions de travail des
professionnels or ce qu'ils réclament
c'est évidemment une reconnaissance de
leur engagement mais surtout pour leur
permette de travailler mieux
or des budgets en hausse ça veut dire
pouvoir recruter du personnel
ça veut dire pouvoir ré ouvrir des lits
et donc en fait nous leur donnons les
moyens de fonctionner pour améliorer
leurs conditions de travail
et évidemment valoriser ceux qui
s'engagent dans des projets et qui ont
un engagement hors normes dans l'hôpital
public
donc tout cela va dans le bon sens c'est
ce que je souhaite dire aujourd'hui en
français c'est que l'hôpital c'est un
trésor national
c'est l'emblème du service public
l'universalité de l'accueil
c'est à la fois la proximité et
l'excellence et là ce que nous avons
choisi de faire c'est non seulement de
le préserver mais de le conforter
comme l'exemplarité du service public à
la française
merci beaucoup et amusant pour votre
réaction
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
réaction à votre micro et je suis
toujours avec denis baranger bonjour
professeur de droit public à
l'université panthéon assas juste votre
réaction est bien c'est toute cette
salle de questions qu'il ya pu avoir sur
l'hôpital on a entendu à la mistral
instants qui parle de trésor national
mais c'est un trésor qui a été largement
malmenées puisque on a aussi eu et bien
une suite de réformes qui ont malmené
l'hôpital et qui ont été cités dans
l'hémicycle oui écoutez c'est des
questions au gouvernement je trouve
assez classique et assez modérée on
aurait pu s'attendre à des joutes
verbales et autres plus brutale après un
rejet du projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale dans son ensemble
par le sénat après des critiques très
dures par les sénateurs sur le
comportement du gouvernement d'un côté
dans cette affaire-là et de l'assemblée
nationale qui a modifié le projet de loi
engagement et proximité on aurait pu
s'attendre donc une après midi un petit
peu plus leur thé au sénat ça va être
qu'à la maison était assez constructif
le président d'abord il a parlé du fonds
ce qui était assez logique mais il n'a
pas évoqué cette question qui semblait
beaucoup l'émouvoir auparavant du du
fait que le président macron avait fait
des annonces qui se retrouvaient pas et
c'était logique dans le texte qui était
en discussions d'où le rejet n'y en a
que je crois pas parler ou quasiment pas
parlé
donc ça c'est une chose tu repars dans
ses réponses on a vu qu'ils cherchaient
la conciliation
je pense que ça traduit un petit peu les
équilibres politiques actuelles au sénat
où d'un côté le sénat se trouve malmené
institutionnellement mais politiquement
beaucoup de gens cherchent la
conciliation que le gouvernement voilà
ce qu'on peut dire et on va tout de
suite se joindre à nouveau la salle des
conférences du sénat car alexandre vous
êtes avec la ministre jacqueline
gourault pour bien sûr parler des maires
c'est un autre sujet dont il a beaucoup
été question tout à l'heure oui
jacqueline gourault les relations entre
l'état et les maires ont
marqué cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement au lendemain
du discours d' emmanuel macron au
congrès des maires de france
et finalement après ce discours qui a
quand même été bienveillants on parle de
câlinothérapie les élus locaux sont
inquiets comment vous l'expliquez
écoutez moi ce matin j'étais au congrès
des maires il y avait la commission
rural de l'association des maires il y
avait deux tables rondes auxquelles j'ai
assisté et j'ai ensuite fait la synthèse
ça s'est très bien passé on a expliqué
concrètement l'agenda rural
toutes les mesures prises pour la
ruralité en france qui ne fallait pas
opposer la ruralité et les villes et les
métropoles qu'il faut y avoir des liens
entre les deux et que la france avait
besoin d'aménagement du territoire de
solidarité entre les territoires pour
que je dirais la société et nos
concitoyens vivent heureux là où il est
en tout ils ont pardon envie de vivre
alors ça s'est très bien passé mais
pourtant on sent un certain
mécontentement des élus locaux des
sénateurs notamment à propos du
détricotage à l'assemblée nationale de
ce projet de loi engagement et proximité
sur des mesures que les élus réclamaient
sur les indemnités des petits élus sur
également leur pouvoir de police
ce détricotage il était nécessaire des
trucages du travail du sénat c'est une
façon de présenter les choses
il ya une loi un projet de loi
gouvernemental comme c'est une loi qui
concerne les collectivités ça commence
par le sénat c'était une loi de 132
pardon 33 articles qui sort à 123
article du sénat le sénat a fait son
travail dans le respect du bicamérisme
maintenant le texte est à l'assemblée
nationale et il ya des députés qui ont
été élus aussi au suffrage universel
direct qui s'intéresse aussi aux
territoires et qui eux votent ou
prennent les décisions
c'est le respect
du bicamérisme de la démocratie et y'a
pas de détricotage c'est toujours facile
de ces l'hémicycle actuellement il ya
juste la commission des lois qui a voté
pour l'instant c'est facile de critiquer
tout sans regarder de près
j'ai pris trois exemples dans la
question d'actualité je peux les
reprendre par exemple sur les indemnités
nous n'avons pas touché à l'amendement
du sénat qui a été présentée par
monsieur matte mathieu darnaud pardon
puisqu'on a trouvé que c'était mieux que
ce que le gouvernement avait proposé
donc on le garde on a réécrit à notre
article sur les compétences facultatives
parce qu'il y avait des histoires
d'écriture législatives s'il fut dur
donc on n'a pas changé
et puis si la commission des lois est
revenu sur le transfert de l'eau et de
l'assainissement dans les conditions
très assouplie que nous avons déjà fait
nous avons toujours dit que c'était la
position du gouvernement et c'est la
position aussi de l'assemblée alors je
veux dire une loi c'est le résultat d'un
texte qui est lui dans deux assemblées
non vous trouvez que les sénateurs
n'accepte pas le travail ça bicamérisme
vous savez que je suis c'est une actrice
moi je suis pour le respect j'ai
toujours été pour le respect de notre
assemblée a mis en scène et le sénat
mais je suis aussi pour le respect de
l'autre assemblée c'est tout à fait
normal
le bicamérisme c'est ça et puis ont pris
s'il y aura une commission mixte
paritaire derrière pour que les deux
assemblées se mettent d'accord ou pas
d'ailleurs
et si elles ne sont pas d'accord pas y
aura une autre lecture je veux dire
laissons la vie démocratique et
législatives se déroulent et enfin je
vous voyez c'est assez simple et je ne
quand je dis cela c'est par respect au
temps du sénat que de l'assemblée
nationale très bien merci beaucoup
jacqueline gourault pour votre réaction
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
nouvelle réaction n'a entendu jacqueline
gourault elle dit un non il faut
respecter le travail de l'assemblée elle
n'est pas en train de détricoter le
texte du sénat il faut aussi respecter
le bicamérisme dans ce sens là qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
côté j'ai pas vocation à défendre le
sénat c'est pas mon rôle mais néanmoins
il était siro nick d'antan dominateur à
côté maintenant c'est pas là c'est pas
la question quoi il ya un petit peu
d'ironie à dire qu elle le rappelle le
sénat au respect du bicamérisme an
l'hypothèse on est dans une situation où
en quelques jours on a eu un rejet d'un
projet de loi de financement de sécurité
sociale par le sénat parce que les
mesures annoncées par l'exécutif ni et
pète n'y était pas et deuxièmement une
modification significative du projet de
loi engagement et proximité sur des
sujets qui tiennent à coeur aux
collectivités locales
la deuxième observation que je vais
faire c'est que ce projet de loi
engagement et proximité c'était une
conséquence qui étaient tirés ou une
réponse qui était donnée au grand débat
national
c'était censé faire plaisir au maire et
défendre les intérêts des collectivités
locales d'où la conclusion que je tiens
que c'est difficile de faire plaisir à
la foule au maire et au sénat voire même
impossible ensuite elle dit la vérité
madame grossir que dernier mot sera
l'assemblée nationale mais ça c'est
c'est le bicamérisme du côté
inégalitaire voilà et bien justement on
va présenter les sénateurs qui nous ont
rejoints en plateau sophie primas
bonjour sénatrice l ère des yvelines
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques merci datera ici avec nous
également sur ce plateau jean yves le
conte sénateurs socialistes des français
de l'étranger membre de la commission
des lois
et enfin nous argent françoise gatel
sénatrice puces et d'ille et vilaine
vous êtes membre de la commission des
lois et vous étiez co rapporteur de ce
texte sur engagement et proximité que
l'on résume aussi parfois sur le projet
de loi sur le statut de l'élu votre
réaction
avait à ce que vient de dire jacqueline
gourault qui dit bien que bien il faut
respecter le travail et qu'il ya eu
et qu'il est en train d'avoir à
l'assemblée sans aucun doute moi je ne
nie pas ça en même temps je voudrais
juste rappeler le contexte le
gouvernement est arrivé avec un projet
de loi qui faisait effectivement écho
aux préoccupations des maires et aux
vraies difficultés qui existent dans
l'application de la loi note donc le
sénat n'a rien inventé
il avait déjà fait un certain nombre de
propositions de ministres le corps nu
s'est félicité de l'intelligence d'un
travail qui était exigeant il n'y a pas
eu de compromis entre le sénat et lui ce
texte était voté par 338 sénateurs sur
348 ou le montrer que tu as c'est génial
d'être dans un travail d'intelligence
voilà bon ensuite cette affaire par à
l'assemblée la commission a une approche
un peu curieuse voilà qui est de mettre
à l'envers puisque nous avions fait
voilà d'une manière parfois un peu
fantaisiste même si on va dire le
rapporteur essaie de contrôler tout ça
et puis à l'assemblée moi j'ai suivi
quelques débats voilà j'ai dit faut être
sérieux sur ces sujets il s'agit pas de
dire l'assemblée a le dernier mot et
vous comprenez nous on a raison ou c'est
non j'ai dit on a une responsabilité par
rapport aux élus locaux qui sont dans
des difficultés après un mandat
extrêmement difficile la population une
attente dont soyons s'il vous plaît tous
un peu sérieux et responsable et je ne
pense pas que le sénat est tricoté un
texte qui choix contraire aux attentes
exprimées par les élus et surtout à
l'objectif proposé par le président de
la république donc à un moment cherchez
l'erreur et j'espère qu'on va se
retrouver en commission mixte paritaire
parce que le sénat n'a aucune volonté
d'obstruction nous n'avons qu'un
objectif le président larcher l'a
rappelé mon corps apportant aussi s'y
servir les communes et quand je dis
servir les élus locaux s'y servir
l'intérêt général
donc là il faut vraiment qu'on soit
touche sérieux responsable d'ong
ressaisissons-nous les uns et les autres
restons zen et serein et avant champ
pour atterrir d'une manière positive
alors on va tout de suite vous donner la
parole mais tout d'abord un petit détour
par la salle des conférences du sénat
car alexandre vous êtes vous êtes avec
vincent eblé
président socialiste de la commission
des finances oui avec vincent eblé on va
revenir sur un épisode qui a marqué
l'actualité ici au sénat alors pour
faire court le gouvernement pour boucler
son budget 2010 9 avaient prévu de
couper 25 millions d'euros dans le
budget de la protection des monuments
historiques
il a eu la colère des sénateurs la
colère de stéphane bern qui a appelé
manuel macron finalement ce budget est
rétabli c'est un peu une victoire du
sénat vincent eblé
oui on peut dire ça c'est pas la seule
inflexion il y en a une aussi j'irai au
bénéfice du budget de la recherche mais
celle là fait plaisir à ceux des
sénateurs qui j'en fais partie se bat
pour le patrimoine et pour la culture de
façon générale effectivement il y avait
un petit rapprochement de montant qui
était facile à faire la création de la
mission berne et le bénéfice de la mise
en place d'un loto du patrimoine
c'était plus de 20 millions d'euros pour
le patrimoine français et puis par
ailleurs on démonte des crédits d'état
des crédits budgétaires sur un montant à
peu près équivalent donc c'était très
facile de faire le rapprochement dix ans
vous vous appelez les français a
contribué par le biais d'un jeu d'argent
à la sauvegarde du patrimoine et puis en
même temps vous en profitez pour réduire
les efforts de l'état dans le même
domaine
donc évidemment c'était profondément
choquant et je crois que cet argument a
fait mouche et le gouvernement a
considéré qu'il ne pouvait pas campé sur
cette position
il est donc venu sur la position
défendue au sénat votée ici de façon
extrêmement large dans l'hémicycle est
donc en commission mixte paritaire nous
nous sommes mis d'accord avec nos
collègues députés
et ces crédits ont été rétablies sont
sauvés donc ce que vous dites c'est que
mercy joue un peu au bonneteau fait des
tours de passe passe avec l'argent du
patrimoine oui c'est un boni taux
s'avère qu'effectivement j'irai en donne
d'une main
ce que l'on sait très bien pouvoir
reprendre de l'autre et ça ça n'est pas
acceptable parce que la politique est la
loi de finances est une affaire sérieuse
ce sont des crédits pour conduire des
politiques publiques
et c'est pas juste un jeu politique de
positionnement des uns et des autres
mais c'est la possibilité pour des
fonctionnaires et l'action publique de
se déployer dans les territoires et là
c'est au bénéfice de notre patrimoine
commun du patrimoine historique de la
france et donc on a souhaité sauver ses
crédits et nous y sommes parvenus très
bien et on va continuer à en parler de
crédit puisque demain à commencer
l'examen du budget au sénat et on espère
qu'il n'y aura pas de tour de bonneteau
de la part de bercy
sophie primas on va parler des mères
mais peut-être juste une très courte
réaction sur ce tour de bonneteau qui a
eu sur le sur le patrimoine
oui c'était complètement
incompréhensible bon c'est un
épiphénomène djelaoui gg l'outrecuidance
de dire que stéphane bern a été berné
mais on va éviter à certains des
français qui ont été 1 ont été bernés on
est assez habitués à ce tour de
passe-passe de et cesser ce jeu de
bonneteau où vous reprendre d'une main
ce que lorsque l'on a donné de l'autre
et et on verra si on parle tout à
l'heure de santé qu'il s'agit un petit
peu de la même chose là en réalité c'est
du redéploiement on est en train
d'étudier les différentes missions du
projet de loi de finances 2009 1 et on
s'aperçoit souvent que les grandes
annonces qui sont faites par le
gouvernement
en réalité c'est du redéploiement de
budget qui était déjà prévu qu'on enlève
d'un côté qu'on remet dans l'autre alors
on l'air ont fait un packaging on fait
un peu de marketing autour et en réalité
c'est du redéploiement de budget on va
parler hôpital de naples est un autre
tour il peut être pas de bonneteau mais
un big bang fiscal qui a fait beaucoup
parler dans les collectivités bien sûr
et bien c'est l'impact de la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation une nouvelle
fois le gouvernement a dit ça sera
compensée à l'euro près ça sera des
ressources dynamiques est ce que vous
faites confiance au gouvernement jean
yves le conte
compte tenu des expériences précédentes
pas tout à fait vous l'avez vu lors des
questions lors des questions d'actualité
et c'est vrai que toutes les annonces
toutes les trajectoires finement qui
sont annoncées et je pensais qu'en quand
j'écoutais sophie primas à la loi 2
de programmation des finances de l'armée
ouais qui présente effectivement une
croissance relativement impressionnante
ceux ci attend quand on regarde le
détail du projet de loi de finances 2010
on s'aperçoit que les armes et compte
tenu de l'effort fait en images doivent
contribuer à un certain nombre d'autres
missions de l'état compte tenu des
efforts qui sont affichés dans le budget
mais qui en réalité ne sont pas réels et
donc c'est systématiquement comme ça
j'ai assez le kurde ont pas toujours
joué avec celle ci est le coeur du
métier des fonctionnaires du ministère
des finances ton qui sont pas contrôlés
par des politiques
or à l'évidence ce jeu ils ne sont pas
contrôlés par les militaires est ce que
vous vous partagez cette crainte
françoise gatel notamment pour les
finances locales
parce qu'on a mais on était en train de
parler du congrès des maires et donc à
l'art de la compensation de la taxe
d'habitation je pense que il ya deux
questions dans cette question il ya la
question vous est posée qui est purement
monétaires aux financières c'est à dire
est ce que il va y avoir une pérennité
du dynamisme des recettes ça c'est un
sujet très sincèrement je pense que ce
qui est donné aux communes peut laisser
penser que financièrement c'est pas elle
qui s'en tire le plus mal c'est beaucoup
plus difficile pour les départements et
ça c'est un vrai sujet par contre moi là
où je suis profondément gêné et j'ai un
désaccord philosophique si je puis dire
que c'est que la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
parce que l on était inégalitaire ce qui
est vrai mais ce que si vrai du foncier
bâti coupe le lien entre l'habitant qui
était considéré comme un citoyen et sa
commune ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui 20
prévus sont faits dès la pause avez vous
avez droit à des services et demain
matin commun on va les expliquer puisque
on ne parlera plus de taxe d'habitation
si on est locataire comme un va
expliquer que la cantine n'est pas
gratuite qu'il n'y a pas plus de
transport puisque ça ne doit rien coûté
puisqu'on ne contribue pas donc je
trouve que se défaire de ce lien de
responsabilité et de contribution à la
vie de la société et un pour moi c'est
un point sur lequel je vraiment je
trouve qu'il ya une profonde de
questions et ça ne participe pas à la
nécessité de responsabiliser à nouveau
chaque citoyen pour comprendre que la
société elle est aussi fait de la
contribution de chacun d'entre nous
sophie primas moi je partage vraiment ce
que vient de dire françoise je pense que
déresponsabiliser les citoyens c'est
orthogonale avec la gestion
participative d'une vie parce qu'en fait
quand vous allez faire des réunions et
vous allez dire faisant un budget
participatif alors tout le monde va dire
je veux une crèche ou la cantine
gratuite je veux du bio dans les
cantines je veux des salles de sport etc
etc je veux un aménagement du territoire
mais quand en face on dire on ne pourra
pas dire eh bien ça ça at elle un impact
sur votre fiscalité
c'est un jeu de dupes c'est un jeu de
dupes que l'on fait en français dernier
aux français de deuxième élément que je
voulais vous dire moi je suis très
inquiète sur la pérennité des
compensations sur la taxe d'habitation
je ne mets pas en doute même pas en
doute la bonne foi du gouvernement
actuel je sais que bercy est à l'affût
je vous rejoins bercy est à l'affût il a
mis le pied dans la porte
il dit aujourd'hui on va vous compenser
à l'euro près la taxe d'habitation mais
dans trois ans dans quatre ans quand la
dynamique des bases de taxe d'habitation
sera tellement forte qu'elle posera
qu'elle pèsera sur le budget de l'état
alors bercy nous dira il faut contribuer
à l'effort de redressement des
financements publics et à ce moment là
on diminuera les compensations
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
un cercle qui nous emmène vers un
véritable problème des finances
publiques
d'autant que monsieur le maire a annoncé
qu'ils auraient une réforme également
des impôts productif pour les
entreprises c'est à dire de la taxe
foncière que payent les entreprises et
donc là ce qui est bien pour les
entreprises mais qui pose un problème
des collectivités territoriales denis
barange votre réaction sur le fait que
les sénateurs anticipe déjà d'être
bernés par bercy potentiellement si à
l'avenir qu'est ce que ça dit quand même
du rapport qu'il ya aujourd'hui entre
bien bercy et les collectivités il
élus locaux c'est une affaire à faire de
défiance quand même c'est une affaire la
sphère budgétaire où tout le monde et
berné et tout le monde est soumis à des
contraintes que personne ne peut
surmonter le gouvernement n'a aucune
marge budgétaire et fiscale est
évidemment le sénat une marge si j'ose
dire de négociation de la discussion
budgétaire dont on sait tous qu'elle est
malheureusement réduite ensuite il ya
quand même les choix de politique
fiscale le choix la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation c'est un choix de
recentralisation tout à fait évident
pour les raisons qui viennent dé dignité
parce qu'on remplace un impôt
directement prélevé au bénéfice des
communes par des compensations qui sont
fatalement qui seront fatalement l'objet
d'ajustements d'arbitrage voire de
négociation tu me donnes je te prends ou
de conditionnalité donc là il ya une
question de politique fiscale qui se
discute au sénat et c'est vrai aussi de
ce que vous avez appelé les
épiphénomènes ça se passe tous les ans
dans la discussion budgétaire et c'est
tous les ans frustrant de constater je
pense pas qu'elle ait grand chose qui
change
sauf que là le gouvernement est soumis à
une contrainte plus forte à la fois
budgétaire et du point de vue de ceux
qui arrivent les points de vue de la
question sociale et gilet jaune de tout
ce qui se passe dans la vie du pays tout
de suite on va retourner salle des
conférences avec alexandre poussard qui
a eu tout à l'heure à son micro
philippe bas le président de la
commission des lois et qui tout à l'air
interrogé justement le gouvernement
autour de la question des mères
philippe bas qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé de la réponse du premier ministre
à votre question où vous dénoncez une
rouste recentralisation notamment de
l'organisation de l'état et des
collectivités
d'abord c'est vrai qu'il ya une
recentralisation qui est rampante et qui
ne cesse de s'affirmer
quand on supprime la taxe d'habitation
pour donner des dotations de l'état aux
collectivités
c'est bien la main de l'état qui
maîtrisera l'avenir des finances locales
quand on part circulaire on bouscule
l'élaboration des plans locaux
d'urbanisme par simple circulaire c'est
aussi l'état qui vient bousculer le
travail parfois de 18 mois des élus
quand on en arrive à un système qui
après sous le règne socialiste
la baisse des dotations et quand même un
système qui gèrent les dotations c'est à
dire qu'il ne prend pas en compte
l'inflation il ya une perte de pouvoir
financer des collectivités locales la
dépendance à l'égard de l'état est sans
cesse sorte et je suis au regret de dire
que le gouvernement ne fait rien pour
inverser la tendance et donc je crois
que la situation mérite vraiment un
sursaut une prise de conscience qu on
entre enfin dans l'acte iii de la
décentralisation
hier le président de la république n'a
rien dit ni la cajoler les maires mais
les maires ne sont pas des faire valoir
la commune n'est pas une nostalgie
c'est l'école de la démocratie c'est la
petite république dans la grande île
faut la respecter et il faut prendre à
bras le corps ces difficultés très bien
merci beaucoup finissent pas pour votre
réaction
le goût de la formule de philippe bas à
la république n'est pas une nostalgie
françoise cathala comme hymne à la
république non plus d'ailleurs mais la
commune dans ce sens là vous aussi vous
avez le sens de la formule puisque nous
sommes chassés avez vous dit 2 du sur
mesure c'est ce que vous aviez prévu
avec le projet de loi engagement et
proximité au prêt-à-porter voire
l'uniforme avec escales prévues le
gouvernement et l'assemblée surtout avec
les modifications qu'elle est en train
de faire sur le texte oui je les dis je
les mêmes pensées puisque je le met
aussi sérieusement que mon propos
sincèrement je pense qu'on a un comment
dire un vrai sujet d'incompréhension et
moi je ne porte aucun de jugement aucun
jugement de personnes sur qui que ce
soit mais je pense qu'au sénat on a une
culture territoria et le nombre
d'amendements que nous avions le nombre
de divergences de points de vue très
amicaux sur la fréquence de la
conférence démarre illustre je dire tout
simplement la diversité des choses est
que la loi ne peut être décidée de paris
pour tout un chacun de la même manière
parce qu'en plus la loi même si elle est
excellente et ici on s'applique à
travailler dans ce sens là elle est mise
en oeuvre localement par des hommes et
des femmes qui ont des histoires des
cultures des géographies différents donc
naturellement et on ne peut pas avoir
deux choses rigide et uniforme ça a été
le corps stage de la loisne autres
aujourd'hui il ya des endroits où le
corse est il en train de lâcher d'une
manière très difficile ce que l'action
publique est contrarié il ya de
l'impuissance et que les élus n'en
peuvent plus donner on dit faisant du
sur mesure tout en encadrant il s'agit
pas dû dire open bar et chacun y va
comme il veut non non on avance de
manière responsable libre et bien ajusté
et monsieur le ministre
cornu n'ai de cesse de nous répéter ce
mot et qui nous trouvait parfois
un peu trop fermé à la liberté qu'on
donnera au maire et dieu sait pourtant
si on a ouvert on a été très novateur on
a même eu des eaux dash à ces remarques
à qui annonçait un projet de loi de
différenciation quand dû plaire au
gouvernement est alors à l'assemblée
ils ont mis à l'envers à partir d'une
idée simple ses dirigeants ils ont
tendance à mettre la vie des
collectivités en équation dont composent
une équation dont il ya une réponse et
c'est une formule que je trouve un peu
trop rigide pour que ça puisse convient
parce que la vie dans les territoires la
vie des gens et des élus elle échappe à
la norme et sincèrement je crois qu'on a
un
comment dire une incompréhension de
cette nature qu'il faut que chacun
progresse pour que sa culture des
collectivités territoriales
s'enrichissent rapidement et de manière
positive
un autre refuge a été largement marqué
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement est menacé
l'hôpital un car il ya eu 1 ce matin
l'annoncé des mesures d'urgence pour
l'hôpital paraît d'un philippe et agnès
buzyn rex très fort tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle en écoutant cette situation
a conduit l'hôpital public à une
situation dont on pourrait dire si on
était dans l'aéronautique qu'elle relève
presque du décrochage
il faut éviter ce décrochage c'est à
dire qu'il faut donner de l'oxygène ou
du carburant cela dépend quel analogie
on veut travailler mais en tout cas de
l'oxygène à l'hôpital public pour qu'il
puisse pour qu'ils puissent passer cette
phase de transformation indispensable
qui a été décrite par madame la ministre
dans le cadre du plan ma santé 2022 et
j'observe que le président billon et je
suis certain que vous l'observez
également que dans les manifestations
dans les remarques qui sont formulées
par les corps intermédiaires auquel vous
comme moi sommes attachés il n'y a pas
la contestation des orientations qui ont
été fixées par madame la ministre dans
le cadre de ma santé 2022 vous le savez
parfaitement
il ya au contraire une forme d'adhésion
qui at il réellement une forme
d'adhésion dans la contestation qui se
fait jour au plan de la santé 2022
jean yves le conte à ce que vous pensez
que le gouvernement allait dans le bon
sens à ce qu'ils disent ils disaient ils
disent juste
on n'allait pas assez vite vous avez eu
la délicatesse de ne pas montrer le
début de la réponse parce qu'avec quand
il indique que
toutes et toutes les difficultés
viennent des 35 heures le personnel
hospitalier sera très content
d'apprendre combien ils travaillent par
semaine et deuxièmement c'est avec un
tel diagnostic ça va être difficile de
répondre aux difficultés actuelles nous
et moi j'ai le sentiment quand même que
lesdits filer les choses qui ont été
proposées ce matin ne représente
représente même pas un millième de
l'ensemble des dépenses de santé
il faut bien bien clairement sur ce
sujet dire que il faut rompre avec la
politique qui a consisté pendant vingt
ou trente ans en france a essayé de
limiter les dépenses de santé en
réduisant l'offre en réduisant l'offre
en dirigeant vers l'hôpital et vers les
urgences et en faisant en sorte que on
arrive à des situations de cette nature
la loi bachelot en en voulant faire des
hôpitaux des entreprises encore aggravé
la situation
donc c'est surtout ça qu'il faut qu'il
faut pouvoir revenir justement sophie
primas tout de même pour revenir vous
dit que le compte n'y est pas mais il ya
tout de même plus un milliard et demi
sur 3 ans sur 2000 19 2022
il ya aussi la reprise de la dette par
celle de l'hôpital 10 milliards sur
trois ans et un nombre de primes qui ont
été annoncées notamment pour
l'ile-de-france
oui alors vous voyez tout à l'heure on
parlait de bonneteau voilà un bon
exemple de bonneteau fait dans le projet
de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale on demande à l'hôpital de faire
4 milliards d'économies pour les trois
prochaines années
donc 4 milliards fois trois ans a fait
12 milliards et là on vient nous
annoncer un milliard et demi sur trois
ans de bonus supplémentaires donc en
réalité vous voyez que les économies sur
le pétale ça sera encore dix milliards
et demi d'économies si on n'est pas
encore tout à fait le texte en plus
comparé le texte est ce qu'on s'est
fâché contre le gouvernement sur des
problèmes de méthode mais on a là un
problème de méthode
j'ai vu qu'il y avait une prime de 800
euros pour le personnel qui travaillait
à paris
mais alors le personnel des rails à
strasbourg il n'a pas le droit à une
revalorisation une prime de primer les
gens qui travaillent dans les grandes
métropoles à mantes la jolie et dans
l'ouest de l'île de france il n'a pas le
droit à cette prime de 800 euros
je ne comprends pas cette mesure je dois
dire je comprends et en fait
arrivant en réalité un problème de
méthode
ça fait le troisième plan d'urgence on a
le mât santé 2022 pardon je ne suis pas
une grande spécialiste de la santé m'ont
à ma santé 2022
on a le programme du rjr de sauvetage d
urgence on a aujourd'hui ce programme-là
62 millions avant l'été 707 millions
nettoyer on sait plus ça pose le
problème de la méthode est sale prose le
problème du sens et salle pose le
problème finalement on a l'impression
d'avoir un canard dont on a coupé la
tête et alors qui va droit à sa dose de
sang et ses 200 milliards donc c'est un
problème de stratégie c'est un problème
de lisibilité et du coup c'est un
problème de considération pour le
personnel de ces hôpitaux en france 4
est ce que vous êtes aussi sévère c'est
vrai que le personnel des hôpitaux il
attend des augmentations de salaires il
attend des lits supplémentaires il
attend des postes supplémentaires sur
les deux derniers enfin même sur ces
trois points on n'a pas tellement
satisfait actifs alors je répondrai en
démarrant par là la remarque de sophie
primas je pense que c'est nécessaire
d'avoir un objectif de la stratégie de
la méthode et si possible d'une
visibilité pour sa ferme en je pense
qu'aujourd'hui dans ce pays sur un
certain nombre de sujets la stratégie
elle est difficile à mettre en oeuvre
parce que il y a un peu le feu partout
et je le dis quand le gouvernement nous
dit voilà moi j'ai hérité de chez moi je
le reconnais aussi ce que je pense que
les 35 heures à l'hôpital ça pas
forcément il était une idée de génie
quand les gens travaillent 70 ou 80
heures quand on ya passé personnel et je
suis pas sûr que madame touraine et
contribuer à aider l'hôpital être en
bonne santé donc voila moi je tiens
quand même aussi à dire ça et qu'on a
besoin la fin vous habitera temps
partagé we will que ce en même temps on
est dans un contexte budgétaire et
financier de ce pays très difficile et
quand je dis qu'il ya le feu c'est à
dire on a vu sur l'école on a vu sur
l'assemblée
les banlieues voix il ya plein de sujets
parce que je pense effectivement que
depuis des années je sais pas si on
allait au fil de l'eau moi je veut
accabler personne mais en tout cas
aujourd'hui il faut à la fois intervenir
comme à l'hôpital
c'est dire il faut intervenir en matière
d'urgence il faut intervenir en matière
de prévention et mettront un certain
nombre de mesures qui permettront
d'apporter des rentes des réponses de
l'urgence et qui sont sans doute à
satisfaisante mais surtout de nous
sortir de l'ornière dans laquelle on met
parce qu'on a aussi décrit sur médecine
de ville
il faut l'avouer on a aussi des
questions en accès aux soins dans l'est
dans les territoires et on a un vrai
sujet au niveau on l'a vu des urgences
et qu'à chaque fois on essaie d'éteindre
un incendie il faut le faire et
sincèrement moi je dis que le
gouvernement qui n'aurait rien fait
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si quelqu'un
m'a dit on ne comprend pas comment il va
simplement dit aux gens n'a pas l'argent
voilà maintenant est-ce qu'on peut aussi
avoir un moment une vision d'ensemble et
travaille aussi sur la prévention sur le
sur le long terme et sur la formation
des étudiants et sortir de cette
médecine en silo ou vous avez un
spécialiste qui ne causent pas assez aux
généralistes qui ne cote pas assez aux
autres acteurs médicaux français y est
elle pour conclure on va terminer sa
note peut-être un petit peu plus légère
quoique sur la question est bien de
l'interdiction de l'alcool au volant
parce qu'il ya eu je la marâtre au
pédalage tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle
à ce propos et bien alexandre poussard à
à son micro d'itélé yom le ministre de
l'agriculture qui avait annoncé dimanche
dernier qu'il était favorable à la
tolérance zéro à l'alcool au volant
didier guillaume vous êtes prononcé en
faveur d'une tolérance zéro contre
l'alcool au volant lors de cette séance
de questions d'actualité
et bien la mise de l'intérieur vient
vient d'assurer qu' il n'y aurait pas de
changement de la réglementation est ce
que c'est un désaveu de vos propos quand
est ce que je me suis prononcé pour une
tolérance zéro en début de semaine non
d'accord vous n'avez jamais tenu une
déclaration sur n'ont su regarder vos
sources on m'a posé une question sur
l'alcool j'ai dit que j'étais opposé au
mois de janvier sans alcool que je
voulais de la modération toute l'année
plutôt qu'un mois de prohibition ya un
journaliste qui me dit et pour le volant
j'ai répondu quand on prend le volant
il omet ne pas boire je n'ai jamais
parlé de tolérance zéro je n'ai jamais
dit que j'étais pour une loi ou quoi que
ce soit moi je pense que quand on prend
le volant il ne faut pas boire parce que
des accidents
je suis contre le fait de modifier la la
loi aujourd'hui c'est 0,5 de toute façon
les scientifiques disent que même si on
ne boit pas il paraît qu'il ya toujours
un petit peu le corps produit un peu des
choses c'est difficile d'être à 0 non il
n'y a pas de sujet il n'y a pas de
désaveu y'a pas moi je suis en phase
avec tout cela
la base de 0,5 me va très bien je n'ai
jamais dit l' inverse je dis simplement
que je lutte contre toutes les
addictions
je vis le faut lutter contre tout
phénomène de deux de boissons trop trop
nombreuses et lorsqu'on prend le volant
c'est tout ce que j'ai dit par rapport
aux jeunes pour avoir tout le monde
il vaut mieux ne pas boire quand
justement moment c'est une clarification
il y avait une inquiétude ans d'ailleurs
la raison de la question du du sénateur
est ce que dans la culture des jeunes de
l'alcool il faut changer des choses faut
faire de la prévention
oui mais nous en faisons beaucoup le
ministère en fait michel de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation le
ministère de la santé en fait évidemment
il faut faire de la prévention
moi je pense que la france est un pays
festif la gastronomie française inscrite
au patrimoine immatériel de l'unesco
j'ai toujours dit que boire du vin était
un bon moment avec des amis lorsque l'on
mange ça c'est pas le sujet mais il faut
faire de la prévention
il faut expliquer que l'alcool c'est
dangereux mais que le vin je la vis
d'une fois j'ai pris les foudres n'est
pas un alcool comme les autres ça veut
pas dire il faut boire différemment je
dis je dis ça je dis simplement que le
vague partie du patrimoine français
ce patrimoine faut le faux le promouvoir
la viticulture c'est une filière
économique c'est de l'emploi
par contre il faut lutter contre toutes
les addictions il faut lutter contre
l'alcool contre le contre l'alcoolisme
pardon et lorsqu'on prend le volant
il vaut mieux ne pas nous
ne pas ne pas boire c'est tout à fait ça
donc si en soirée si on prend le volant
pas de verre devant c'est ce que vous
dites non je dis simplement que
aujourd'hui il ya une loi qui est une
loi 05 il faut maintenir le 05 et que si
on est à + 0 5
eh ben on est fautif si on est à moins
de 0,5 c'est d'un cadre de la loi la loi
c'est la loi dura lex sed lex
merci beaucoup diegem au moins vos
propos sont clairs c'est pas facile de
faire leur même temps sur la question du
vin défense du terroir et en même temps
il ne faut pas aller être favorable aux
addictions en eau dit le ministre de
l'agriculture sophie primas ouais je
trouve que c'est une polémique pour
faire une polémique voilà je suis pas
sûr qu'ils voulaient dire ça je suis pas
sûr que ça nécessite tous brûla je crois
qu'il ya des sujets aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont bien plus importants mais il faut
pas croire que voilà au sénat on défend
le 90 de rouler à 90 en étant
alcoolisées voilà donc je veux pas non
plus aller dans les quatre caricatures
je pense quand il faut de la mesure
c'est la marque du sénat et voilà je
pense que c'est une fausse polémique
j'arrive le contre ça confine un petit
peu à la caricature de la caricature je
dire sur le fond bon on peut conduire on
peut boire mais il faut choisir c'est en
même temps voilà c'est surplombe reste
d'actualité mais pas les deux en même
temps voilà ça serait une ligne
politique françoise gatel oui oui c'est
un leurre en même temps à ses limites
on a bien vu moi je dis voilà chacun
reconnaît que le vin peut être quelque
chose qui fait partie de notre
patrimoine voilà bon et très sincèrement
aujourd'hui on peut pas défendre l'idée
que quelqu'un doit pouvoir boire et
conduire sont susi voilà faut être clair
sur la prévention de la sécurité et les
addictions de manière générale et le vin
enfin mais c'est le ministre à ma
connaissance mais je suis pas
scientifique
le vent m'a t'on dit aussi un alcool
voilà donc c'est quand même sincèrement
je suis dit oh boy
cerise que peut-être parce que l'air du
temps permet aussi parfois de baisers
sur des choses yeux voilà qui sont
sérieuses mais je pense qu on a aussi
beaucoup de choses sérieuses ne pas
crier nouvelle mêmes fondamentaux
voilà l'autre aussi d'aider des fraudes
et des dysfonctionnements dans notre vie
démocratique et nomade notre capacité à
prendre des décisions en commun parce
que je ne le fait pas et mégane on se re
tout le monde se retourne vers le
président et le gouvernement alors que
la démocratie c'est d'abord ça se décide
ici les budgets de la politique elle se
décide par les budgets merci fait la
politique un de sujets graves et deux
sujets les pas d'une manière à bord dont
la prise et dont il ya certaines
réponses faut pas plaisanter avec ça on
en plaisante pas mais on a le sourire
quand même merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à ce débrief des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement merci sophie
primas françoise gatel merci à jean yves
le conte merci beaucoup denis baranger
de nous avoir accompagnés tout au long
de cette émission très bonne soirée à
tous sur public sénat dans un instant ne
manquez pas allons plus loin avec
rebecca fitoussi semaine spéciale depuis
le congrès des maires porte de
versailles à très bonne soirée à tous
sur public sénat
[Musique]